Sean, good morning. I know that this is, it's a weekend morning. I know it doesn't line up with, you know, the episode people are about to listen to, but it's an actual Saturday when we're recording this. That's correct. Be honest. You're playing for the day. Go be fucking ruthless with yourself right now. Totally. I'm going to have, I'm not even kidding. I'm going to have a chili cornbread casserole right when this is over. Oh no, no, no, but tell us something unusual. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less.
肖恩，早安。我知道这是一个周末的早安。我知道这和大家即将收听的那期节目可能对不上，但我们录音的时候确实是星期六。没错。老实说。你今天在消磨时间。现在就对自己狠一点吧。完全是这样。我甚至不开玩笑。等这个结束，我马上就要吃辣椒玉米面包砂锅。噢不，不，不，但跟我们讲点不寻常的事吧。欢迎来到 SmartLess。Smart。Less。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Oh Sean get a good stretch in you look a little kitty cat stretching. Wait listen I have a story to share with you all. Here we come. Is that why you had to stretch for your story? Yeah.
Smart。Less。Smart。Less。噢，肖恩，伸个懒腰，你看起来像只伸懒腰的小猫。等等，听着，我有个故事想跟大家分享。来喽。这就是你刚才得为讲故事做拉伸的原因吗？对啊。
Is that what just happened? Yeah. Did you write notes or are you just going to kind of free it? Oh no this is serious. Look at the look on his face. I know because I don't know if this has ever happened to you, but two days ago I'm in my car, I'm on Wilshire Boulevard in between appointments
刚刚发生的就是这个吗？对啊。你写了笔记还是打算自由发挥？噢，不，这很严肃。看他脸上的表情。我知道，因为我不知道这事有没有在你身上发生过，但两天前我在车里，在威尔希尔大道上，在两个约会之间
because if I drive home by the time I get there, I have to come back. So I'm driving around like 20 minutes trying to kill time. So I'm driving, you don't pull in somewhere. Yeah, you're just burning fossil fuel because. Well, it's an electric car. All right. It's an electric car. It doesn't charge for free, you know, go ahead.
因为如果我开车回家，等我到那儿了，我又得赶回来。所以我开车到处转了大概20分钟，想消磨时间。所以我开着车，你怎么不找个地方停下来。对啊，你只是在燃烧化石燃料，因为。嗯，这是一辆电动车。好吧。这是一辆电动车。你知道，它充电可不是免费的，你接着说。
Okay, so. It does mitigate it somewhat, okay, go ahead. So I'm in the center lane on Wilshire Boulevard in Beverly Hills and the car goes dead. And I have plenty of battery and I'm freaking out. And the display on my dashboard says. Neutral. Is your.
好吧，所以。它在某种程度上确实减轻了影响，好吧，你接着说。所以我开在比佛利山庄威尔希尔大道的中间车道上，然后车子抛锚了。我的电量还很充足，而且我快急疯了。仪表盘上的显示屏写着。空挡。你的。
Is your key in the car. That's what it said. And you're wondering what neutral means? Stupid ass. I was like. It says we're going nowhere. First of all, by the way, first of all, has your car ever broken down in the middle lane
你的钥匙在车里吗？它就是这么写的。然后你还在琢磨“空挡”是什么意思？大笨蛋。我当时就。上面写着我们哪儿也去不了。首先，顺便说一句，首先，你的车有没有在中间车道抛锚过
and like a busy, like the stress is crazy. Yeah. Did you get out and try to start pushing your car? No, but I freaked out. I put on my hazards. Everybody's driving by like, fuck you. And I'm like, what am I supposed to do? My car died.
而且是在像那种很繁忙的路上，那种压力太疯狂了。对啊。你有没有下车试图推你的车？没有，但我吓坏了。我打开了双闪。每个人开车经过时都像是在说：去你的。而我在想：我该怎么办？我的车抛锚了。
Then it says the key, the thing on the display on the dashboard said is your key in the car, if so hold it up to the designated area. And I'm like, what's the designated area? Anyway, I freaked out. So I take the, this is the longest story in the world. I took the manual out, and while people are driving past me, like crazy, I'm.
然后它上面写着，钥匙，仪表盘显示屏上的那个东西写着“钥匙在车里吗？如果是，请将它放在指定区域。”然后我在想：什么是指定区域？不管怎样，我吓坏了。所以我拿出了，这是全世界最长的故事。我把说明书拿出来，在人们疯狂开过我身边的时候，我。
Oh, so you weren't alone, manual was with you. What, did you see him in the back seat? But you took him out, right? So he was, it must have been in the trunk. So you let manual out. Yeah, and I asked him what was wrong. So you're reading the manual manual and meanwhile you're screaming, guys stop honking.
噢，所以你不是一个人，说明书跟你在一起。什么，你看到他在后座了吗？但你把他带出来了，对吧？所以他，他肯定在后备箱里。所以你把说明书放出来了。对，我问他怎么了。所以你在读说明书，而与此同时你一直在尖叫，大家别按喇叭了。
I know. It's not my fault. Have you ever had that happen? Like I was so stressed out and so I have my head down, I'm looking at the manual, looking for like keys or whatever, like key fob and they say, anyway, so anyway, I panic and I call Scotty. Scotty's like, what do you want me to do about it?
我知道。这不是我的错。你们遇到过这种事吗？我当时压力太大了，所以把头埋得很低，看着说明书，找钥匙或者别的什么，比如智能钥匙，他们说，总之，总之，我惊慌失措，然后我给斯科蒂打了电话。斯科蒂的反应是：你想让我怎么办？
Yeah. And so I. With a tone and I call Scottie. Scottie's like, what do you want me to do about it? And so I... With a tone. I'm freaking out and I find a YouTube video of a guy who went through the same thing in the same kind of car. And he's like, you got to put it in the cup holder. I'm like the cup holders. I put the key in the cup holder and I hit it again.
对啊。然后我。带着那种语气，我给斯科蒂打了电话。斯科蒂的反应是：你想让我怎么办？然后我……带着那种语气。我吓坏了，然后在YouTube上找到了一个视频，讲的是一个开同款车的家伙也遇到了同样的情况。他说，你得把它放进杯托里。我在想，杯托？我把钥匙放进杯托里，然后重新发动了一下。
Thank God it started. But that was like 20 minutes sitting there with my hazards on. And then I finally, cause I'll be damned if I didn't make to my massage. So I got to my massage'll be damned if I didn't make my massage. So I got to my massage. That was your appointment. That was my appointment because I hadn't had one in like a year.
谢天神谢佛，车终于发动了。但在那里亮着双闪坐了大约20分钟。最后我，因为哪怕豁出去我也得去按摩。所以我要去按摩了。就算豁出去我也得去做按摩。所以我去按摩了。那是你的预约。那是我的预约，因为我大概有一年没做过按摩了。
Sounds like a real busy day. Middle of the day massage? Yeah, yeah, middle of the day. Middle of a workday massage? Okay. So, and you give me shit, JB, for not going to the office. This guy's doing middle of the weekday massages. Wait, this is the end of the story.
听起来真是忙碌的一天啊。大白天做按摩？对啊，对啊，大白天。工作日的中间去做按摩？好吧。所以，JB，你还总因为我不去办公室而数落我。这家伙居然在工作日大白天去做按摩。等等，这是故事的结尾。
You're living like a fucking Saudi prince over here. Look at this guy. So wait, the end of the story is, I get out of my massage, I just passed the front desk, because I already paid, and she goes, oh wait, and she could tell she was too embarrassed to say the word husband, so she goes, your friend dropped off a spare key.
你过得就像个沙特亲王一样。看看这家伙。所以等等，故事的结尾是，我按摩完出来，刚走过前台，因为我已经付过钱了，然后她说，噢等等，她能看出她太尴尬而说不出“丈夫”这个词，所以她说：“你朋友送来了一把备用钥匙。”
So I used my spare key. He dropped, Scotty drove all the way to the thing to drop off a spare key that I didn't even know I had. While you were getting a massage. Your roommate, your roommate came. Your roommate came by. Your roommate, I know that you're a confirmed bachelor, and your roommate came.
所以我用了我的备用钥匙。他送，斯科蒂一路开车到那儿，送来了一把我都不知道自己有的备用钥匙。就在你按摩的时候。你的室友，你的室友来了。你的室友顺道过来了。你的室友，我知道你是个坚定的单身汉，而你的室友来了。
The guy in the other room. Oh, poor Sean. Oh, God, that was the worst. Oh, poor Sean. Oh, God, that was the worst. Sean, has anything ever happened like that? I mean, I have had that issue. It's called a car breakdown. It's the worst feeling. No, but I have had that thing with the key,
隔壁房间的那个人。噢，可怜的肖恩。噢，天哪，那太糟糕了。噢，可怜的肖恩。噢，天哪，那太糟糕了。肖恩，有过类似的事情发生在你身上吗？我的意思是，我确实遇到过那种情况。这叫汽车抛锚。那是种糟糕透顶的感觉。不，但我遇到过那种关于钥匙的情况，
like it has to be, it's not being recognized, but usually I just, usually just move it around to different points of the car. Who, but they don't tell you that? Like how, I was not supposed to know. Yeah, there's a picture usually. It shows like a little picture somewhere on your screen where to stick it.
比如它必须是，没有被识别出来，但通常我只是，通常只是把它拿到车的不同位置晃晃。谁，但他们不告诉你吗？就像，我本来不该知道的。对，通常会有个图示。屏幕上的某处会显示一个小图示，告诉你该把钥匙贴在哪。
But anyway. Anyway, yeah. Great story. Did anybody stop for a selfie with you? No, I had my head down so far looking at the book. Did you think that maybe you should pop the trunk or the hood so that no one rear ends you or honks at you and just signify... Well, I had my hazards on.
不管怎样。不管怎样，对。很棒的故事。有人停下来跟你自拍吗？没有，我把头埋得太低，一直在看书。你当时有没有想过，也许你应该打开后备箱或者引擎盖，这样就不会有人追尾你或者向你按喇叭，只是为了示意……嗯，我开着双闪呢。
It didn't work. You have one of those like little like triangular orange reflective things in the trunk of your car. Like a cone. Do you snap a flare off? Whereabouts in Wilshire, whereabouts? But by the way, I was in the thick of it. I was like Wilshire, like just off of Santa Monica
没用。你车后备箱里难道没有那种像小三角橙色反光标志的东西吗？就像路锥一样。你有没有折断一个发光棒？在威尔希尔的哪个地段，具体在哪？但顺便说一句，我当时正处在核心地段。我就在威尔希尔，差不多就在圣莫尼卡刚过去的地方
and like, you know, Rodeo, like in the middle of that section. Oh, in Beverly Hills? Yes, in the middle lane. Lucky you didn't get mugged. So your fancy car breaks down on Wilshire and Beverly Hills on your way to your massage. You do well in the war theater. Hey, listen, man, and the price of eggs
就像，你知道的，罗迪欧，就在那一带的正中间。噢，在比佛利山庄？对，在中间车道。幸亏你没被打劫。所以你那辆豪车在比佛利山庄的威尔希尔大道抛锚了，正赶着去按摩。你在战区表现得不错。嘿，听着，伙计，鸡蛋的价格
must be crushing you right now. You're just going nuts over this, right? Guys, it's a great segue. I've got a guest that can answer a lot of high stress driving questions for you. Oh, good. Today, we've got a guest that's going to prove to you, too, that hard work can bring great results. Fellas, if you just show a little discipline and focus, read a book for God's sakes and apply yourself, you can reach great heights, Will.
现在一定把你压垮了吧。你简直要为这事疯狂了，对吧？伙计们，这是一个绝妙的过渡。我今天请到了一位嘉宾，他能回答你们很多关于高压驾驶的问题。噢，太好了。今天，我们请到了一位嘉宾，他也将向你们证明，辛勤的工作能带来伟大的成果。伙计们，如果你们能表现出一点纪律性和专注力，看上一本书，看在上帝的份上，并全身心投入，你们就能达到伟大的高度，威尔。
Sean. Okay, I'm working on it. This guy was named valedictorian in high school, voted most likely to become president. He went on to graduate college magna cum laude and that would be from BT Dub, Harvard. Then he was awarded a Rhodes Scholarship to study at Oxford, so he did that. Graduated first class honors in philosophy, politics, economics, and he came home and spent his time between serving in Afghanistan
肖恩。好吧，我正在努力。这家伙在高中时被评为毕业典礼致词代表，被投票选为最有可能成为总统的人。他后来以优异成绩（magna cum laude）从大学毕业，也就是顺便提一下，哈佛大学。然后他获得罗德奖学金前往牛津大学深造，所以他去了。以哲学、政治、经济学一等荣誉毕业，他回国后把时间分配在阿富汗服役
and mayor at 29. Oh, I know this fella. He's since served four years as United States Secretary of Transportation and hopefully his high school class is right and he'll be our president one of these days. That's an honor to have on SmartList, Mr. Pete Buttigieg. Woo! Hey guys.
以及在29岁时当选市长。噢，我认识这位老兄。他随后担任了四年美国交通部长，希望他高中同学的预言是准的，他有朝一日能成为我们的总统。很荣幸能请到他来到SmartList，皮特·布蒂吉格先生。哇！嘿，伙计们。
Hi there. Now, so can you explain to Sean because in Afghanistan, you were driving, were you not? Yeah, yeah, that was a big part of my job. High stress driving. And so what would you suggest to him there on Wilshire and Rodeo? Should he pop his trunk so he doesn't get rear-ended? In Afghanistan, you definitely would not want to open
你们好。那么，你能向肖恩解释一下吗，因为在阿富汗时，你一直在开车，对吧？对，对，那是我的主要工作之一。高压驾驶。那么对于他在威尔希尔和罗迪欧的遭遇，你有什么建议吗？他应该打开后备箱以免被追尾吗？在阿富汗，你绝对不会想要打开
any part of the vehicle. This happened one time. Pop a flare, perhaps. Actually knocked a mirror off the first time I was driving. Come on, Pete. Yeah, got in big trouble because you couldn't just stop and pick it back up. Right. And, you know, Will Sharpe Boulevard, much like Central Cobble, I imagine, is a place
车辆的任何部分。这种情况发生过一次。也许可以点燃一个发光棒？事实上，我第一次开车的时候还撞掉了一个后视镜。拜托，皮特。对啊，惹了个大麻烦，因为你不能就那么停下来把它捡回来。没错。而且，你知道的，威尔希尔大道，我想就跟中央鹅卵石路一样，是一个
where you can watch your back. Kind of dangerous. Watch your back, be careful. But JB, but as Secretary of Transportation, you might have some advice for people like Sean, whose Porsche is broken down. It's amazing how many people just don't want to stop and help. No, exactly. They just want to keep driving by. Now, do the up-armored Humvees even have hazard lights?
需要你时刻提防的地方。有点危险。注意安全，小心点。不过，JB，作为交通部长，你或许能给肖恩这样保时捷抛锚的人一些建议。令人惊奇的是，有那么多人根本不想停下来帮忙。不，确实如此。他们只想一直开过去。话说回来，防地雷反伏击车（MRAP）有双闪灯吗？
I didn't even get a Humvee. It was a slightly up armored Toyota truck. It was a Highlander, I think. That's kind of cool. Yeah, well that's all they drive there, right? Pickups. Yeah, they love their Hiluxes. That's kind of the go-to vehicle out there.
我连防地雷反伏击车都没开过。那是一辆稍微加装了装甲的丰田卡车。我想是一辆汉兰达。那挺酷的。好吧，那确实是他们在那儿开的所有车，对吧？皮卡。对，他们特别喜欢海拉克斯（Hilux）。那基本上是那里的标配车辆。
At least it was in my day. Hilux, I don't know that. I'm not familiar with that term, Hilux. Yeah, I think they only sell those abroad, but it's really big over there. I mean, there's nothing like seeing a pickup, a Hilux storming your way with like 12 guys in the back and a 50 cal mounted roughly on the, you know?
至少在我那个时代是这样的。海拉克斯，我不知道这个。我对这个词不熟悉，海拉克斯。对，我想他们只在海外销售，但在那边真的很火。我的意思是，没有什么比看到一辆皮卡，一辆海拉克斯气势汹汹地朝你驶来，后面坐着12个家伙，还大致架着一挺50口径机枪更震撼的了，你知道吗？
Dangerous, it's dangerous. Yeah, it gets your blood flowing. Sure, sure. And now, and so you were driving top speed, looking out for the road mines on your way to reconnaissance and things like that, and that sounds very stressful. Yeah, yeah, it was pretty stressful. But the folks I was with were really good at their jobs.
危险，这很危险。对，这让人热血沸腾。确实，确实。现在，所以你当时全速驾驶，在前往侦察等任务的路上提防着路上的地雷，听起来压力非常大。对，对，压力确实挺大。但和我一起的那些伙计们工作极其出色。
I was well-trained in my job. So we called it military Uber, basically making sure people in gear could get to where they need to go. Would you ask your passengers to rate you favorably? You know, I should've. Yeah. So you know, I'm getting reacquainted with Uber now, because I, you know, for the last four years,
我对自己的工作也受过良好的训练。所以我们称之为军事优步（Uber），基本上就是确保人员和装备能够到达他们需要去的地方。你会要求你的乘客给你好评吗？你知道的，我本该这么做的。对啊。所以你知道的，我现在正在重新熟悉优步，因为我，你知道的，在过去的四年里，
I would still drive, like if I was dropping off the kids at school or something like that, but most of the time I was being driven. That's how it works when you're in the cabinet. So I had to get Uber back on my phone and get used to all that. It's changed a little bit since I remember. You've got more options now.
我还是会开车，比如送孩子们上学什么的，但大部分时间我都是被司机载着。当你身处内阁时，情况就是这样的。所以我不得不把优步重新下载到手机上，并习惯这一切。它跟我记忆中的有点不一样了。你现在有更多选择了。
Yeah, but nobody can accuse you of being highfalutin, continue. We mentioned your service in the armed forces. Like you, what an incredible career you've had. I'm really impressed by it. It's unbelievable. That you went to Harvard, you're a Rhodes scholar. Are you impressed by it, Will?
对，但没人能指责你趾高气扬，你继续。我们提到了你在军队的服役经历。就像你一样，你的职业生涯太不可思议了。我真的印象深刻。这太难以置信了。你去了哈佛，还是罗德学者。你印象深刻吗，威尔？
I mean, did you hear of the book? It's unbelievable. Of course you are. He was in something that you would never get assigned to. He was an intelligence officer. Okay. Yeah, what does that mean? So, he's gonna tell us right now.
我的意思是，你听说过这本书吗？这太难以置信了。你当然印象深刻了。他从事过你永远不会被派去的工作。他曾是一名情报军官。好吧。对，那是什么意思？所以，他现在就要告诉我们了。
Well, I could tell you, but then I'd have to, you know. Yeah, then you'd have to. Oh, please kill him. Wait, so. I could tell you, but then I'd have to, you know. Yeah, then you'd have to. Oh, please kill him. Wait, so. So, on the podcast, the ratings would be phenomenal. It'd be review. But what an unbelievable,
嗯，我可以告诉你，但那样的话我就得，你知道的。对，那你就得。噢，拜托，杀了她吧。等等，所以。我可以告诉你，但那样的话我就得，你知道的。对，那你就得。噢，拜托，杀了她吧。等等，所以。所以，在这个播客上，收视率会好得惊人。这会是篇评论。但这真是不可思议，
when you were sort of 15 in high school, you couldn't have imagined the sort of the trajectory your life was going to take, could you? No, there's no way. When I was 15 in high school, all I wanted to be was an airline pilot, which I still think is an amazing job. I respect pilots so much.
当你大约15岁读高中时，你一定想象不到你的人生会走向这样一条轨迹，对吧？不，完全想象不到。我15岁上高中的时候，我只想成为一名航空公司飞行员，我到现在依然觉得那是一份了不起的工作。我太尊敬飞行员了。
By the way, it's a great job. It pays very well and it's very in demand, but I thought that was the coolest thing ever. My dad would go on business trips sometimes. Mine too. And they would have, on the wide body planes, they would fly over the Atlantic. They used to have this custom where they'd pin up
顺便说一句，这是一份很棒的工作。它薪水很高，而且非常抢手，但我当时觉得那是世上最酷的事情。我父亲有时会去出差。我父亲也是。在那些宽体客机上，他们会飞越大西洋。他们过去有一个习俗，就是把
a carbon copy of the flight plan. I don't know if you ever saw this. It'd be about the size of a small poster, and they would stick it to the wall in the back of the plane. I think this was before they had monitors where you could see where the plane was. So it would show the track
飞行计划的碳复写件贴起来。我不知道你们有没有见过这个。大概有一张小海报那么大，他们会把它贴在飞机后部的墙上。我想这应该是在他们拥有能看到飞机位置的监视器之前。所以它会显示
of where the plane was supposed to go in this kind of carbon line on this map. And anyway, if you asked, they would give it to you. And so he would bring them back for me when he came back from a trip and I just wallpapered my room with them. I was so obsessed. I knew the names of the pilots that had signed the things.
飞机应该飞行的航线，在这张地图上用这种复写纸的线条画出来。不管怎样，如果你向他们索要，他们就会给你。所以他每次旅行回来都会给我带这些，我把我的房间贴满了这种壁纸。我当时太着迷了。我都认识那些在上面签名飞行员的名字。
They were like celebrities to me. Did you ever consider getting your pilot's license and joining the Air Force instead of the Navy? So I discovered some things about my eyesight that meant that I was not going to be a candidate for military aviation. Same, same. Colorblind, right? Oh, that was the reason. Not colorblind. about my eyesight that meant that I was not going to be a candidate for military aviation. Same, same.
他们对我来说就像名人一样。你有没有考虑过考取飞行员执照，然后加入空军而不是海军？我当时发现自己的一些视力问题意味着我没有资格参加军事航空。我也是，我也是。色盲，对吧？噢，原因就是这个。不是色盲。关于我的视力，这意味着我没有资格参加军事航空。我也是，我也是。
Colorblind, right? Oh, that was the reason. Not colorblind. Wait, hang on a second. Sorry, sorry, Mayor Pete. So Sean, your kind of fuzzy vision derailed a long career as an aviator? I thought you were going to your colorblind because you can't be a pilot if you're colorblind, and I'm colorblind.
色盲，对吧？噢，原因就是这个。不是色盲。等等，等一下。抱歉，抱歉，皮特市长。所以肖恩，你那种有些模糊的视力毁了你作为飞行员的漫长职业生涯？我以为你要说你是色盲，因为色盲不能当飞行员，而我是色盲。
Yeah, no, it just had to do with how near-sighted, I think now it's not such a big deal, but I was so near-sighted that astigmatism, you like, at least in the 90s, like you can look forward to a career. No colorblind, that's a thing. Oh, you've got headphones, I've got headphones too. That's so crazy.
对，不，这只是跟我的近视程度有关，我想现在这已经不算什么大问题了，但我当时近视得太厉害了，还有散光，你知道的，至少在90年代，你根本别指望能有这样一个职业生涯。没有色盲，那是另一回事。噢，你戴着耳机，我也戴着耳机。这太疯狂了。
That's a whole subplot in what's the, Little Miss Sunshine, right? There's a whole subplot around it. Yeah, that's very good, very good. So then, all right, so then your vision kept you, all right, so then, but what about, now there wasn't, both of your parents are academics and educators,
那是哪部电影里的一个完整副线剧情，是《阳光小美女》，对吧？里面有一个围绕这个展开的完整副线剧情。对，非常好，非常好。所以，好吧，所以你的视力阻碍了你，好吧，所以，但是，现在难道没有，你的父母都是学者和教育工作者，
but there's no, is there military in your family at all? What got you to lean that way? Yeah, there is, yeah, not at my, not my parents' generation, but before that, a lot in my family were career military. Matter of fact, when I was growing up, we had a portrait painting in the living room of this army officer.
但是没有，你的家族里有人从军吗？是什么让你倾向于那个方向？对，有的，对，不是在我父母那一代，但在那之前，我家族里有很多人都是职业军人。事实上，在我成长过程中，我们客厅里挂着一幅这个陆军军官的肖像画。
And we were, you know, I mean, my parents were professors, middle class, neighborhood Indiana. We were not like portraits of ancestors on the wall kind of family. So it always stood out to me and I asked about it. And the story, it turns out, it was my great uncle who died in a plane crash in 1941, but he was an Army Air Corps officer, which is the predecessor to the Air Force. And the reason that painting exists is because his brother, my grandfather, was also an officer.
而且我们是，你知道的，我的意思是，我的父母是教授，中产阶级，印第安纳州的社区。我们不是那种会在墙上挂祖先肖像的家庭。所以这总是让我感到很显眼，我就打听了这件事。故事原来是这样的，那是我的大伯，他在1941年的一次飞机失事中丧生了，但他是一名陆军航空队军官，也就是空军的前身。那幅画之所以存在，是因为他的兄弟，也就是我的祖父，也是一名军官。
He was a doctor, actually, he was an Army doc. And at a, I guess there was a prisoner of war camp in I think New Mexico, where World War II prisoners would interact with American officers. And he got to know an officer who could paint and asked him if he would paint from a photograph this portrait of his brother who had been killed. And he did.
实际上他是一名医生，是一名陆军军官。在，我猜是在新墨西哥州有一个战俘营，二战战俘会在那里与美国军官接触。他认识了一位会画画的军官，并请他根据一张照片画一幅他已经牺牲的兄弟的肖像。他照做了。
And so I grew up with this, he's kind of sitting in a classic World War II style army uniform, kind of staring right at you. And I felt like it was kind of my family's version of the Uncle Sam poster, you know, saying like, why not you? Why aren't you serving your country? I want you.
所以我从小就看着这幅画，他穿着经典的二战风格陆军制服坐着，直直地盯着你。我觉得这就好像是我家族版本的“山姆大叔”海报，你知道的，上面写着：为什么不是你？你为什么不为国效力？我们需要你。
And I think that was in the back of my mind. It was a big part of why I wanted to serve. You know, and then like a lot of people my age, 9-11 had a big impact on me. And then when I got to Oxford, often some of the Rhodes Scholars are graduates of the military academies, West Point Naval Academy.
我想这一直留在我脑海的某个角落。这也是我想去当兵的一个重要原因。你知道的，然后就像很多我这个年纪的人一样，9·11事件对我有很大的影响。接着当我到了牛津时，罗德学者中经常有军事院校的毕业生，比如西点军校、海军学院。
And my class had quite a few and I respected those guys so much. It was one more reason I wanted to serve. And so I entered the reserve once I got back and kind of started my professional life. I joined a reserve unit, and it was one weekend a month, two weeks a year, but then part of the deal is if they call you up, you go.
我的那一届有很多这样的人，我非常尊敬那些家伙。这是我想去当兵的又一个原因。所以我一回到国内开始职业生涯就加入了预备役。我加入了一个预备役部队，一个月一个周末，一年两周，但协议的一部分是，如果他们召唤你，你就得去。
And I got called up while I was mayor, actually. So I put my mayoral service on hold. I took a leave. I had a deputy mayor who stepped in for me for the time I had to go and went off to Afghanistan. Is there any part of it you miss? Yeah, actually, yeah. I mean, the people, most of all.
事实上，我正当市长的时候就被召唤了。所以我把市长的职务搁置了。我请了假。在我必须离开的那段时间里，有一位副市长代行我的职责，然后我就去了阿富汗。有没有什么部分是你怀念的？对，其实，是的。我的意思是，最怀念的是人。
Of course. The people I served with, and they were totally different from each other and from me in every way, different politics, different upbringings, but we all just really trusted each other and looked out for each other. And it's something, yeah, I wish, obviously the military's not for everybody,
当然。和我一起服役的人，他们在各方面都跟我以及彼此截然不同，不同的政治立场，不同的成长背景，但我们彼此真正信任，互相照顾。那是某种，是的，我希望，很显然军队并不适合所有人，
but I think a moment like this is one where it would be great if more people had some experience of doing something hard together with other people that just builds that kind of trust that we don't seem to have enough of right now. Can you talk about that moment to the extent you're comfortable, when you got that call that you actually were going to go overseas and serve,
但我认为像这样的时刻是一个很好的时机，如果更多的人能有一些与其他人在一块儿共同经历艰难险阻的经历，就能建立起那种我们现在似乎相当缺乏的信任。你能谈谈那个时刻吗？在你方便的范围内，当你接到电话得知自己真的要去海外服役时，
because I'd imagine a lot of folks join the service and it's not during wartime and they never get in combat. And you're going over, it's gotta during wartime, and they never get in combat. And you're going over, it's gotta be somewhat frightening. Can you talk about that? Yeah, your first day, like. Or that you're gonna go, time to pack your bags. Yeah, I mean, you take a deep breath and it's sobering, but it's also, it's a big part of why you serve.
因为我想象很多加入军队的人，如果不是在战时，他们就永远不会经历战斗。而你要去那里，那一定是在战时，这多少会有点吓人。你能谈谈吗？是的，你的第一天，比如。或者说你要出发了，是时候收拾行李了。是的，我的意思是，你深吸一口气，这让人清醒，但这也是你选择参军的一个重要原因。
I mean, of course, if you're agreeing to put on the uniform, you're putting your right hand up and taking that oath, that means the whole idea is you're going to be there if your country needs you. And, you know, I had one tour in Afghanistan. I spent a little time also in Afghanistan and Iraq as a civilian economic advisor, but I was with people who served four, five, six tours.
我的意思是，当然，如果你同意穿上军装，举起右手宣誓，那就意味着整个核心理念就是，如果国家需要你，你就会挺身而出。而且，你知道的，我在阿富汗有一个轮换期。作为平民经济顾问，我也在阿富汗和伊拉克呆过一段时间，但我身边的人都是经历过四次、五次、六次轮换的。
It was incredible how many, my generation, how many tours some of them did. And so I was really humbled to see how much other people had served. And that's one of the other things that made me want to do in the first place, was seeing a lot of other people in my generation rogering up to go and thinking at a certain point,
不可思议的是，我们这一代人中有那么多人经历了那么多次轮换。所以我看到其他人的付出时感到非常谦卑。这也是让我一开始就想参军的原因之一，当我看到我们这一代人中有那么多人响应号召奔赴前线，并在某个时刻心想，
like when's it my turn? But does fear enter into it? Oh, of course. Yeah. Yeah. The first night I was there, they train you for what a rocket alarm sounds like, obviously, you know, what to do if you hear the alarm that says incoming.
什么时候轮到我？但恐惧会产生吗？噢，当然。对啊，对啊。我在那里的第一天，他们会培训你火箭弹警报听起来是什么样的，很明显，你知道的，如果听到警报说有袭击该怎么办。
I started out at Bagram, Bagram Airfield, and then later on was reassigned to Kabul, the capital. But that first night at Bagram, there was a rocket attack and I just remember just my blood running cold when I heard that sound. It's the same sound, by the way, as I think it's called, there's an iPhone alarm that's the exact same.
我一开始在巴格拉姆，巴格拉姆空军基地，后来被重新分配到首都喀布尔。但在巴格拉姆的第一晚，发生了一次火箭弹袭击，我只记得当我听到那个声音时，我的血都凉了。顺便说一句，那声音跟，我想那叫什么来着，有一个iPhone闹钟的声音完全一样。
Oh, the eh, eh, eh, that kind of thing? Yeah, yeah. It would be a great idea to just never use that. Yeah, no kidding. On your iPhone. At least if you're around somebody who might have memories around that. But yeah, my first day there was a rocket attack,
噢，那个呃、呃、呃的声音？对，对，对。如果永远不用那个声音，那绝对是个好主意。对啊，不开玩笑。在你的iPhone上。至少如果你身边有人可能对那种声音有记忆的话。不过是的，我在那里的第一天遭遇了火箭弹袭击，
my last day there was a rocket attack. Wow, it's probably a different sound than when my massage is over. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's more of a gong. Yeah, and probably more fear than like JB when you got the call that you were going to be in Heart to Heart, Secrets of the Heart, the TV movie.
我在那里的最后一天也遭遇了火箭弹袭击。哇，这听起来可能跟我的按摩结束时的声音不太一样。对，对，对。那个更像是个锣声。是的，而且恐惧感可能比JB你接到电话说你要去演电视电影《心心相印，心灵的秘密》时要多得多。
Yeah. Like that must have been. When I'm asked to force my call tomorrow, you know, it's going to be, yeah, yeah. But well, listen, Mayor Pete, thank you for your service. Yeah, it's really, really impressive. Now, with your father being a professor of literature, did that, I mean, were you, stupid question,
对啊。那感觉一定。当明天有人叫我强行参军时，你知道的，那将会是，对，对。不过，皮特市长，谢谢你的服役。是的，这真的，真的很让人印象深刻。现在，鉴于你的父亲是文学教授，这是否意味着，我是说，你是，这问题有点蠢，
but I mean, I'm just, I love listening to you talk. I, by the way, I do too. Right. And I love, anytime you're on any news channel, anything, anywhere, I'm like, you're the smartest person in the room. I love watching you debate. I love watching you debate.
但我的意思是，我只是，我喜欢听你说话。顺便说一句，我也喜欢。没错。我喜欢，只要你在任何新闻频道、任何节目、任何地方出现，我就觉得你是房间里最聪明的人。我喜欢看你辩论。我喜欢看你辩论。
I mean, cause you make debating not seem like debating, you just boil it down and you take the contention out, which is great. Well, a lot of debating now isn't actually debating. It's just like a media opportunity, right? It's just people kind of saying their canned things. But your ability to shape a thought, your opinion, just to make it kind of tangible for folks,
我的意思是，因为你让辩论看起来不像是辩论，你只是把它精简，剥离了其中的争论，这太棒了。嗯，现在的很多辩论其实已经不是真正的辩论了。它只是一次媒体机会，对吧？人们只是在说一些套话。但你塑造思想、表达观点的能力，能让这些对大众来说变得切实可行，
I appreciate, because me not smart. But I love that you spend time on Fox, too. And that there's an ability to, I love that you spend time on Fox too. And that there's an ability to, because we all need to kind of stop talking across one another and talk together. And so I love that you spend some time over there. Is there a reason why more Democrats aren't talking over there,
我很欣赏，因为我不聪明。但我很高兴你也花时间去福克斯新闻（Fox），而且有能力去，我很高兴你也花时间去福克斯新闻。而且有能力去，因为我们都需要停止各说各话，而是坐下来共同交流。所以我很高兴你花时间去那边。有没有什么原因导致更多的民主党人不愿去那边说话，
are they not invited or do they not wanna go? I just wish they'd do it more. Yeah, I think. I'm both, yeah. Look, there's a lot of reasons to hesitate, right? If you're going into a place that you know is not ideologically friendly or not aligned with you, like there's reasons to think twice about it, and I think a lot of people in my party do,
是他们没被邀请还是不想去？我只是希望他们能多去一些。是的，我想。两者都有，吧。看，犹豫是有很多原因的，对吧？如果你要进入一个你知道在意识形态上对你不友好或与你不一致的地方，三思而后行是有理由的，我想我党内的很多人确实会这么想，
but my take on it is you can't blame somebody for not embracing your message if they've literally never heard it. And a lot of people will never hear what we have to say if we're only talking to people who are friendly to us. And it's not just TV. I mean, it's also, I'm doing more podcasts, more digital stuff, just because I know
但我的看法是，如果别人压根没听过你的主张，你就不能怪他们不接受。如果我们只跟那些对我们友好的人对话，很多人就永远听不到我们要说的话。而且这不仅仅是电视。我的意思是，这也是为什么我越来越多地上播客、做数字媒体，只是因为我知道
that's where a lot of people get their information. I've been teaching one day a week at the Institute of Politics in Chicago, at the University of Chicago there. And one of the things I do is I'm always asking my students whenever we sit down, a lot of times I'll do a show of hands, where do you get your news? The number of students who raised their hands
那是很多人获取信息的地方。我每周在芝加哥政治研究所，也就是那里的芝加哥大学教一天课。我做的一件事就是，每次我们坐下来时，我总是会问我的学生们，很多时候我会让大家举手示意，你们从哪获取新闻？当我问他们有多少人从电视获取新闻时，举手的学生数量
when I asked how many of them get their news from television was zero, like literally zero. They might see a clip from TV if it goes into their TikTok feeds or Instagram or something like that. But I don't think of myself as that much older than them, but I grew up in a world where you watch the TV story about some controversy. You heard the conservative opinion,
是零，字面意义上的零。如果电视上的某个片段被发到了他们的TikTok或Instagram信息流里，他们可能会看到。但我并不觉得自己比他们大多少，但我成长在一个这样的世界：你会看电视上关于某个争议的报道。你会听到保守派的观点，
you heard the liberal opinion, and maybe hearing the other side made you feel the way you feel even more strongly, or maybe it made you change your mind a little bit, or ask another question. But the point is you think about it. You stop and think about it. And it's very hard for that to happen now,
你会听到自由派的观点，也许听到另一方的观点会让你对自己的立场深信不疑，也许会让你稍微改变一点想法，或者提出另一个问题。但重点是你会去思考。你会停下来思考。而现在，以我们媒体运作的方式，这很难发生了。
the way our media works. So I'm trying to cut through some of those categories. Well, glad you're doing it. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. I think one of the tricks that they've done on both sides, and this is what has sort of made me, I think a lot of other people check out
所以我正努力冲破那些刻板的分类。很高兴你能这么做。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。我认为他们在两党身上采用的一个伎俩，也是让我以及许多其他人对整个过程
from the entire process is, is that the truth is we all want a better system, we all want a better country, we all want a better America. Everybody wants everybody to be better fed and all, et cetera, just whatever the issue is. Everybody wants everybody to be better fed, and all, et cetera, just whatever the issue is. Everybody wants that. And somehow we've been convinced by a few people
感到心灰意冷的原因，就是真相其实是我们都想要一个更好的系统，我们都想要一个更好的国家，我们都想要一个更好的美国。每个人都希望每个人能吃得更好，等等，不管是什么议题。每个人都希望每个人能吃得更好，等等，不管是什么议题。每个人都想要这个。而不知怎么的，我们被少数人说服了，
that we are at odds with each other. And I think that everybody is actually a lot more aligned. I think so too. Than we think. I think so too. I truly believe that. Yeah, look, obviously there's some serious disagreements and differences in values, but there's also,
认为我们彼此对立。但我认为实际上大家的共识要多得多。我也这么认为。比我们想象的要多。我也这么认为。我真的坚信这一点。对，看，显然我们存在一些严重的意见分歧和价值观差异，但同样地，
yeah, you look at a lot of the biggest issues. There's like 60, 70% of Americans who agree on what to do about it. And if you look at the overlap, that might not be the same 70% from this issue to that issue, but the big things that people want out of everyday life and the big things people want their government to do
你看许多最大的议题。有60%、70%的美国人在该怎么做上达成了一致。如果你看看重叠的部分，在不同的议题上可能不是那同一群70%的人，但人们对日常生活的大诉求，以及人们希望政府为他们做的大事情，
for them to have stuff work, clean, safe drinking water and clean air and roads that don't have a hole in them and transit that gets you to where you need to go and an economy where you can afford stuff and enough housing. Like these are the things that everybody wants and we've gotten into this mode where politics
为了让一切顺畅运转的大事情，干净、安全的饮用水，洁净的空气，没有坑洼的道路，能把你带到目的地的公共交通，一个让你买得起东西的经济环境，以及充足的住房。这些都是所有人想要的，而我们却陷入了这样一种模式：政治
is treated like a, basically like a wrestling death match. And it does, I think, turn a lot of people off. But you know, my experience, and maybe it's because I came up locally and local politics, by the way, as everybody knows, can be very, very rough and tumble, but there's this sense in a community, you're a little more, it's a little clearer to everybody
被当成了一场摔跤生死战。我认为这确实让许多人感到厌恶。但你知道，我的经验，也许是因为我是从基层做起，而正如每个人所知，地方政治也可能非常非常激烈混乱，但在一个社区里有一种感觉，你会更，对每个人来说更清晰的是，
that everybody wants the community to do well. Well, and you also have to answer to each other face-to-face, day-to-day. Yeah, you see each other at the grocery, walking the dog, like, yeah. And yeah, I think we really missed that at the national level. You know, Washington has its version of that
每个人都希望社区过得好。而且你们还得日复一日、面对面地对彼此负责。对啊，你在杂货店、遛狗时会碰到彼此，就像，是的。是的，我认为我们在国家层面上真的很怀念这一点。你知道的，华盛顿有它自己的那一套，
because you like run into other political figures, but it's not like being part of the same thing. Yeah, but it seems to me, and again, this is forgive me for sort of boiling it down like this, but it does seem to me that Washington politics are a lot like the WWE. It's like everybody goes and puts on their game persona and then back in the locker room,
因为你会遇到其他政治人物，但这不像是成为同一事物的一部分。是的，但在我看来，再次原谅我把它简化成这样，在我看来，华盛顿的政治确实很像美国职业摔角（WWE）。就像每个人都去换上他们的比赛人设，然后回到更衣室里，
they're like, hey, that was a pretty good one. Yeah, that was a good one by you too. They all know, everybody knows each other. Do you know what I mean? I think it was like that. I think that's changed a lot in the last few years, if you talk to people who just some of the things that are really dark, January 6th, that kind of stuff,
他们会说：“嘿，刚才那一摔真不错。”“对啊，你刚才那下也很棒。”他们都心知肚明，每个人都认识彼此。你知道我的意思吗？我认为过去是这样的。如果你跟经历过过去几年一些真正黑暗的事情——比如1月6日那种人们真的为生命感到恐惧的事件——的人谈谈，你会发现情况已经发生了很多变化。但是的，你确实能感觉到，我们花了将近四年时间，虽然我不是一直住在华盛顿，但我任职的大部分时间我们都住在那里。这是一个新闻标题。他，布蒂吉格承认他没有一直住在
where people were really fearing for their lives, I think has shifted that a little bit. But yeah, you could definitely feel, we spent almost four years, I wasn't living in Washington the whole time, but most of the time I was serving, we lived there. There's a headline. He, Buddha Judge admits he wasn't living
华盛顿。我们开始吧。不，你知道是怎么回事，是我到处旅行。我因为工作原因，每周至少有一两天在外面旅行。然后，你知道的，因为我的工作部分是去全国各地考察我们正在进行的工程项目。很显然，你是交通部长。
in Washington the whole time. Here we go. No, you know what it was, is I was traveling so much. I was traveling a day or two a week minimum for work. And then, you know, because my job was to, partly to go around the country and look at the projects we were working on. You know, you're in charge of transportation, obviously.
你到处旅行。我把每个州都至少去了一遍。哇。然后，你知道的，有时我也因为竞选的事情到处旅行，开始意识到，对我们家族来说，我在华盛顿呆的那些天住酒店，比在那里付房租、还要付我们在居住的密歇根州的房贷要更划算。而且对我们来说，让孩子们和祖父母呆在一起很重要。所以我母亲，他们的祖母现在住在特拉弗斯城。
You're traveling a lot. I went to every single state at least once. Wow. And then, you know, there were times that I was traveling a lot for campaign stuff too and began to realize that it was, for our family, it was more economical for me to stay in a hotel the days I was in Washington
我们搬到这里很大程度上是因为查斯坦的父母，我丈夫的父母在这里。
than to pay rent there and mortgage here in Michigan where we live. And it was important to us for the kids to be around their grandparents. So my grandmother, or my mother, their grandmother lives here in Traverse City now. We moved here largely because Chastain's parents, my husband's parents are here.
那是他长大的地方。把孩子们留在父母身边，这带来了截然不同的改变。对，对。那么，是什么让你在那么小的年纪就觉得自己能当市长并涉足政坛？你在29岁时就当选市长了，对吧？对，对。所以从阿富汗回来，哦不，
That's where he grew up. And it's made all the difference in the world to have the kids close to their parents. Yeah, yeah. Well, what made you think that you could become a mayor and get into politics at that early age? You became mayor at 29, I think? Yeah, yeah. Like, so coming back from Afghanistan, well no,
这是在你去阿富汗之前，但从牛津回来后，你去，你在咨询公司工作。在哪个时间点你觉得自己可能想涉足政坛？对，我在牛津读完书，在芝加哥的一家咨询公司找到了一份工作，但随着我越走越远——
this is before you went to Afghanistan, but coming back from Oxford, you'd go, you worked for the consultant firm. At what point did you think, I might want to go into politics? Yeah, so I finished up at Oxford, got a job in Chicago at a consulting firm, but the further I got-
麦肯锡，对吗？你在那里吗？对，麦肯锡，对。我在那儿学到了很多，但我也很快发现客户服务不适合我。我对这事不够关心。我想从事我真正关心的事情，
McKinsey, is that right? Is that where you were? Yeah, McKinsey, yeah. And I learned a lot there, but I also figured out pretty quickly that client service wasn't for me. I just didn't care enough about it. I wanted to work on something I cared about,
不仅仅是因为拿人钱财而去关心，而是因为它对我真的很重要。与此同时，很多人都知道印第安纳州的南本德是圣母大学所在地。但很多人没有意识到的是，圣母大学其实是在印第安纳州南本德的街对面。它并不是那种意义上的大学城。
not just because I was being paid to care about, but because it was really important to me. And meanwhile, a lot of people know that South Bend, Indiana is where Notre Dame is. What a lot of people don't realize is Notre Dame's actually across the street from South Bend, Indiana. It's not a college town that way.
这座城市完全是围绕汽车工业建立起来的。它是斯图贝克（Studebaker）的单企业城镇。斯图贝克总部就设在印第安纳州南本德。尽管这家公司在60年代就倒闭了，但当我在80年代和90年代长大的时候，这座城市仍在试图从那场打击中恢复过来，人口流失严重，空置废弃的房屋和倒塌的工厂随处可见。
And the city was completely built around the auto industry. It was the company town for Studebaker. Studebaker was headquartered in South Bend, Indiana. And even though that company went out of business in the 60s, when I was growing up in the 80s and 90s, the city was still trying to recover from that, lost a bunch of its population, vacant abandoned houses, collapsing factories everywhere.
所以我是在这种理念的熏陶下长大的：成功意味着逃离。我的意思是，所谓的“铁锈带”和美国农村地区的很多孩子从小接受的信息就是这样，对吧？如果你想有所作为，就离开这里。这基本上也就是我做的事情。我去了东海岸，然后走得更远，拿了奖学金去英国留学。
And so I grew up kind of inhaling this idea that success meant getting out. I mean, a lot of kids in the so-called Rust Belt and in rural America grow up with this message, right? If you want to make something yourself, get out. Which is pretty much what I did. I went to the East Coast, then I got even further away, going to the UK to study when I got the scholarship.
但随后我开始意识到，我走得越远，就越意识到我其实是有根的。并开始对自己的出身和家乡的潜力产生了一种近乎战斗般的自豪感。我发现许多跟我一起长大的伙伴也有同感，我们的城市可以变得更好，可以拥有一个不同的未来。就在我决定竞选市长的那个时候，
But then I started to realize, the further away I got, the more I realized that I was actually from somewhere. And started to feel this almost militant pride in where I was from and what it could be. And I found that a lot of people I grew up with felt the same way, that our city could be more than it was and could have a different future. And right around the time I got in the race for mayor,
但随后我开始意识到，我离开得越远，就越意识到我其实是来自某个地方的。我开始对自己的出身以及它可能成为的样子产生一种近乎激进的自豪感。我发现许多和我一起长大的人也有同感，我们城市可以变得比过去更好，可以拥有一个不同的未来。就在我参加市长竞选的那段时间里，
there was a national write-up of our city, they call it one of America's 10 dying cities. And we hated that so much and didn't believe it. And so, I found that there were enough people who felt the same way that we could build this campaign. We had a lot, by the way, it was super bipartisan. I ran as a Democrat, but we had a lot of independents, Republicans who supported it.
当时有一篇全国性的报道写到我们城市，称它是美国十大垂死城市之一。我们对此恨之入骨，根本不相信。后来我发现有足够多的人有同感，我们可以发起这场运动。顺便说一句，我们得到了很多支持，这是一场超级两党合作的运动。我是以民主党人的身份参选的，但我们得到了很多无党派人士和共和党人的支持。
And then they put me in charge of the city. And then it was put up for shut up. It was cool. Was that as frightening put up or shut up. It was amazing. Then I had to. Was that as frightening as getting the call up to go overseas? I mean, you know, did you get all that responsibility?
然后他们让我负责管理这座城市。接着就是动真格的时候了。这很酷。那就像是被征召去海外一样可怕吗？我是说，你当时承担了所有的责任？
You know, I took office on New Year's Day and it was snowing. And one thing I knew a lot about was just that. You're hungover. I knew. Yeah. You know, one thing you definitely need to be on top of is mayor's snow plowing. Sure. Maybe not as much an issue, obviously. Not out here. One thing you definitely need to be on top of as mayor
你知道，我是在元旦那天上任的，当时正在下雪。我非常清楚的一件事就是，你宿醉了。我知道。是的。你知道，作为市长，你首先要抓的一定是除雪工作。当然，这可能不是一个太大问题，显然，在我们这里不是。作为市长，你首先要抓的一定是
is snow plowing. Sure. Maybe not as much an issue obviously. Not out here. Where you are. But right in the lake effect zone, a lot of snow, and it's kind of the test of the classic test of a mayor. So right away there's this trial by fire,
除雪工作。当然，这可能不是一个太大问题，显然，在我们这里不是。在你所在的那个地方。但在湖泊效应降雪带，雪下得很大，这可以说是对市长的一场经典考验。所以一上任就是严峻的考验，
just making sure that we were okay dealing with the snow. And yeah, it's everything from, yeah, I worked on everything from police and fire to streets and to the zoo. Like we were in charge of the zoo. Anything surprising about a mayor job that would surprise people, something you didn't expect?
确保我们能妥善应对降雪。是的，从警察和消防到街道，再到动物园，所有事情我都要管。比如我们还要负责动物园。关于市长这份工作，有什么让人意想不到、会吓到大家的事情吗？
I was surprised to be in charge of the zoo. It just wasn't something I thought about when I was campaigning. I didn't know I'd be dealing with golf courses as much. We had city golf courses that I was managing and I don't even golf. And then things that you hear about but I didn't really think much of it until I did it.
我竟然要管动物园，这让我很意外。我在竞选时根本没想过这事。我不知道自己还得花这么多时间处理高尔夫球场的事。我们要管理城市高尔夫球场，可我连高尔夫都不会打。还有一些事情，你以前听说过，但在亲身经历之前，你根本不会去多想。
You get to marry people, right? You are. Oh wow. Oh, yeah, of course. Justice is the... And I remember one time I came in, I was really early, I was the first person in, so my staff weren't around,
你可以给人证婚，对吧？是的。哦，哇。哦，对，当然可以。司法权力是……我记得有一次我来得很早，我是第一个到的，所以我的工作人员都还没来，
and I stepped out of the elevator in the hallway that leads to the mayor's office, and this other couple, these two other people stepped out of another elevator and said, oh, mayor, we were hoping we'd find you here. Like, just who we were hoping to see. And I thought, okay, I hope I'm ready for whatever they're gonna ask
我从电梯里走出来，来到通往市长办公室的走廊上，另外一对伴侣，也就是另外两个人从另一部电梯里走出来说：“噢，市长，我们正希望在这里找到你呢。”就像是“太好了，正想见你呢”。当时我想，好吧，不管他们问什么，我希望我都已经准备好了，
because I'm all alone up here. And then they explained, she was super pregnant. And they said, well, we're on our way to the hospital, we're gonna have a C-section, and by the time we tell her parents that they're grandparents, I wanna make sure we're actually married. So could you marry us? Wow.
因为我一个人在这上面。然后他们解释说，女方怀孕非常明显。他们说，嗯，我们正赶往医院要做剖腹产，在告诉她父母他们要当爷爷奶奶之前，我想确保我们真的已经结婚了。所以你能给我们证婚吗？哇。
And it's time sensitive. Like now? Yeah, yeah, like right now. So I don't know everything about their story. And you're like, yeah, I could, but I've assigned all marriages to the zoo, so we got to get to the zoo real quick. So we did it, like I went through my drawers
而且时间非常紧迫。就现在？对，对，就现在。所以我不了解他们故事的全部。你会想，是的，我可以，但我把所有证婚都指派给动物园了，所以我们得赶紧去动物园。于是我们就办了，我翻了翻抽屉，
and I found like somewhere in there from the last time I did this, I had a copy of the protocol, the things I was supposed to say, and my staff trickled in while we were putting that together and I found a piece of pipe cleaner we were able to use just as a makeshift ring. And they ran down and got the certificates
在里面某个地方找到了我上次做这事时留下的仪式流程副本，也就是我该说的话的台词。在我们整理这些东西的时候，我的工作人员陆陆续续地进来了，我还找到了一段管道疏通毛刷，我们可以把它当成临时戒指。他们跑下去拿了证书，
and I signed off. Wow. Yeah, but by the time they got them married and squared away and then they went off. I mean, was she in labor while you were giving, I mean, was she like breathing, whatever that is? Like, was she about to go into it? I'm not sure I would have been able to handle that.
然后我签字了。哇。是的，但等他们结完婚、把事情办妥后，他们就走了。我是说，你主持仪式的时候她已经在宫缩了吗？我是说，她当时在深呼吸或者什么的吗？她是快要生了吗？我不知道自己当时能不能应付那种情况。
Yeah, yeah, that would have been crazy. Now, how does that differ from your first day as transportation secretary? What was that like? Was it, what is day one like when you're handling that large department? Well, it's a huge leap. So as mayor at about a thousand employees and about a $300 million organization. So not small, but as Secretary of Transportation, you've got 55,000 employees. You oversee everything from commercial space travel,
对，对，那太疯狂了。那么，这和你在交通部长第一天的工作有什么不同？那是什么感觉？当你负责这样一个庞大的部门时，第一天是什么样的？嗯，这是一个巨大的飞跃。作为市长，我大约有1000名员工，机构预算大约为3亿美元。所以规模不算小，但作为交通部长，你有55,000名员工。你监管着从商业太空旅行、
safety to the Great Lawrence Seaway, to the Maritime Administration, to just so many things. And the budget is the size of a mid-sized country. It's about $150 billion, or at least it was once we got the infrastructure package through. Wow, that's crazy. It's pretty daunting. The really daunting thing was it was deep COVID
安全到圣劳伦斯海道、海事管理局等方方面面的事务。预算规模相当于一个中等国家的规模。大约是1500亿美元，至少在基础设施法案通过后是这样的。哇，太疯狂了。这相当令人望而生畏。真正令人畏惧的是，当时正处于新冠疫情最严重的时候，
and I couldn't be in a room with most of my staff. And then, that was the time when the protocols were extremely intense. I got exposed to, I was in a room with somebody who had had COVID and it was decided that I needed to be confined for 14 days, just in case. So the first time I participated in an Oval Office meeting, they wheeled a television into the Oval Office so that I could participate
我无法和大多数员工共处一室。而且，那是防疫规定极其严格的时候。我曾和一个感染了新冠的人呆在同一个房间里，因此决定必须对进行我14天的隔离，以防万一。所以，我第一次参加椭圆形办公室会议时，他们把一台电视机推进了椭圆形办公室，以便我能够
by Zoom from this apartment where I was locked up. And and and join remotely. So it's a very strange introduction to the job. It's a very strange introduction to my own team, but gradually we built a really good chemistry with a really good team full of public service. But the irony that you're now the Secretary of Transportation but you can't go anywhere.
通过Zoom从我被关起来的公寓里参与会议，并远程加入。所以这是一次非常奇怪的入职体验。对我自己的团队来说也是一次非常奇怪的介绍，但渐渐地，我们与一个充满公共服务精神的优秀团队建立了一种非常好的默契。但讽刺的是，你现在是交通部长，却哪里也去不了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. As you know. Yeah, and Pete, instead of asking you what we would never know, like what we could never guess about the transportation, like safety, like I don't think I can handle that answer, I don't want to know what I don never know, like what we could never guess about the transportation, like safety, like I don't think I could handle that answer. I don't want to know what I don't know. So I'll just say, what is the most interesting thing
对，对，对。如你所知。是的，皮特，我不问那些我们永远不会知道的事情，比如我们对交通安全的种种猜测——我觉得我无法应对那个答案，我不想知道那些我不知道的事，比如我们对交通安全的种种猜测——我觉得我无法应对那个答案。我不想知道我不知道的事。所以我只想问，关于这一切是如何运作的，
that you learned that you could share with us about how it all works? Because it is kind of fascinating. Yeah, I don't want to know about safety stuff. I think I wouldn't be able to sleep. You want to present yourself? Oh, the safety stuff should be reassuring though. Yeah, all right.
你学到的最有趣、能与我们分享的事情是什么？因为这确实挺吸引人的。是的，我不想知道安全方面的事情。我想我晚上会睡不着觉。你想自我介绍一下？哦，安全方面的事情其实应该让人放心才对。好吧，好吧。
I mean, one thing that people don't think about is how incredible of a civilizational achievement our overall aviation safety record as a country is. There was a terrible crash this year. There was 15 years with no fatal crashes. Wow. And that doesn't just happen, right? I mean, think about what that takes.
我是说，人们没有想到的一点是，作为一个国家，我们整体的航空安全记录是一项多么不可思议的文明成就。今年发生了一起可怕的坠机事故，但在那之前，我们有15年没有发生过致命坠机事故。哇。这可不是凭空发生的，对吧？我是说，想想这需要付出什么。
I wish we had that on auto safety. We don't, like on the ground, like in cars, we lose more than 100 people a day in this country. It's one of the big things I worked on. We finally got the numbers starting to go down again on my watch. Are those numbers, are a lot of those numbers still the result of people being intoxicated?
我希望我们在汽车安全方面也能做到这一点。但我们没有，在地面上，比如在汽车里，我们这个国家每天有超过100人丧生。这是我着手解决的重大问题之一。在我任职期间，这些数字终于开始下降了。这些数字，其中很大一部分仍然是由于人们酒后驾车造成的吗？
Is that, or is it a lot of texting? Both, yeah, distracted driving is a huge deal. I mean, I cannot emphasize enough how important it is to just put down the phone, just don't, it can wait. But anyway, the work that goes into making sure people are safe, and stuff I never thought about in shipping, like making sure that things that go into packages are safe.
是这样吗，还是因为很多人发短信？都有，是的，分心驾驶是个大问题。我是说，怎么强调放下手机的重要性都不为过，就是别看，它可以等一会儿。不管怎样，为了确保人们安全所付出的努力，以及我在航运中从未想过的事情，比如确保包裹里的东西是安全的。
We learned things like there was a cottage industry of custom kind of homemade nail polish, which sometimes is using compounds that were unsafe to put in the mail. Again, not on my bingo card for things I would be dealing with, but it was a thing. Yeah, because can't you mail anything? I mean, how do they find out?
我们了解到一些情况，比如曾经有一小群人制作定制的自制指甲油，有时会使用不安全的化合物放进邮件里。再次声明，这不在我需要处理的事情清单上，但它确实存在。是的，因为难道不是什么都能寄吗？我是说，他们是怎么发现的？
Not hazardous materials. Asking for a friend, Sean. But that's the thing, people don't know, like if you're like on Etsy, you know, selling custom nail polish, you don't think of yourself as a person who ships hazardous materials, right? You think of yourself as a small business.
危险品不行。肖恩，我这是替朋友问的。但问题就在这里，人们并不知道，如果你在Etsy上出售定制指甲油，你不会认为自己是一个运输危险品的人，对吧？你觉得自己只是一家小企业。
And so, you know, trying to do that without overregulating everybody to where nobody could do anything. Jason, quick, do you know what Etsy is? She's Sean's cat. Thank you so much. Alright, Sean's cat. Cat, my cat.
所以，要想在不进行过度监管、导致谁也干不了任何事实的前提下处理好这件事……杰森，快告诉我，你知道Etsy是什么吗？她是肖恩的猫。非常感谢。好吧，肖恩的猫。猫，我的猫。
Come here, Etsy. So Sean, did you get enough of an answer there for a friend about how to properly mule something? Yeah. What to look for, how they can. No, I always thought that because, you know, like gummies are legal, but you can't mail them. Here we go.
过来，Etsy。所以肖恩，关于如何正确走私东西，你从朋友那里得到满意的答案了吗？是的。找什么，怎么操作。不，我一直以为因为，你知道的，软糖是合法的，但你不能寄。这就开始了。
You know what else I learned a lot about? Fish. Fish. I wound up having to learn more than I thought I would about fish. Why, why? Because a lot of fish, you know, famously swim upstream. And if a road is built through a stream or a river
你知道我还学到了很多关于什么的事吗？鱼。鱼。我最终不得不学习比我想象中更多的关于鱼类的知识。为什么，为什么？因为很多鱼，众所周知是逆流而上的。如果在溪流或河流中修建道路，
and you don't put the right kind of culvert so the water can go under it, it blocks the fish passage. And it turns out a lot of roads were built in the 60s and 70s. The culverts either weren't built the right way or they failed over the years. And it was screwing up fisheries, especially in the Pacific Northwest,
却没有安装正确类型的涵洞让水从下方流过，就会阻断鱼类的通道。事实证明，很多道路是在20世纪60年代和70年代修建的。涵洞要么建得不对，要么多年来已经损坏。这把渔业搞得一团糟，尤其是在太平洋西北地区，
but this is happening all over the country. And so we started working on fixing it with some of the funds in the infrastructure package. Huge deal for the Pacific Northwest, especially for tribal communities, but also just in general. So I ended up having, you know, in PowerPoint briefings on the difference
但全国各地都在发生这种情况。于是我们开始利用基础设施法案中的一些资金来着手修复。这对太平洋西北地区来说是件大事，尤其是对部落社区而言，对整体来说也是如此。所以最后，我有了一份关于洄游鱼（逆流而上）和降海鱼（我记得这是顺流而下的鱼的称呼）之间区别的
between anadromous fish, which swim upstream, and I think catadromous, I think is the word for the ones that fish go downstream. And it's not just salmon. I mean, there's a lot of fish related things that turn out to be at stake. But Pete, you know, like you look at, I've never been to Japan,
PowerPoint简报。而且不仅仅是三文鱼。我是说，有很多与鱼类相关的事情最后都受到了影响。但是皮特，你知道，你看，我从来没去过日本，
but everybody I know that's been to Japan is like, every street is flawless. Everything is clean. Every like road and it's- Sean, you would love Japan for real. I know, I really want to go, but you go, God, there's a Sean, you would love Japan for real. I know, I really wanna go. But you go, God, there's Hunt League, you just said the budget.
但我所有去过日本的朋友都说，每条街道都完美无瑕。一切都很干净。每一条路都……肖恩，你会真的爱上日本的。我知道，我真的很想去，但你会觉得，天哪，肖恩，你会真的爱上日本的。我知道，我真的很想去。但你会觉得，天哪，有亨特·利（Hunt League），你刚才提到了预算。
How is it, and I can only speak to Los Angeles, every road I drive on has massive potholes all the time. What's going on? Yeah, so some of it is you get what you pay for, and that's a country that just really invests in its transportation. But they also have a culture of taking care of things that I think we could learn from.
怎么会这样——我只能代表洛杉矶发言——我开车的每一条路上都有大量巨大的坑洼。到底是怎么回事？是的，所以部分原因是你花多少钱就得到什么服务，这是一个真正投资于交通的国家。但他们也有一种爱护事物的文化，我觉得我们可以从中学习。
I went there because they hosted the G7, all the transport ministers from the G7 countries get together and it was their turn to host. And this great meeting, but yes, it's kind of solid up close, got to ride the bullet train and see how it runs on the bullet train, which is an incredible experience. But there's a culture, like it's,
我去那里是因为他们主办了G7峰会，G7国家的交通部长们聚在一起，轮到他们主办了。这是一次很棒的会议，是的，近距离看真的很坚固，我还坐了子弹头列车，看看它是怎么运行的，这是一次不可思议的体验。但他们有一种文化，就像是，
like you don't eat while you're walking in Japan. Couple of us made this mistake and learned very quickly you're not supposed to do that. Like you don't just walk down the street with an ice cream cone or a sandwich. Because why? Which is, it's just, you're supposed to stop and eat at a table, and then they give you,
你在日本走路时是不能吃东西的。我们有几个人犯了这个错误，很快就吸取了教训，知道不应该那样做。就像你不能拿着冰淇淋蛋筒或三明治走在街上一样。因为什么？这是因为，你应该停下来在桌子旁吃，然后他们会给你，
if you get something to go, they give you a little bag to put your trash in that you take with you. Wow, that's incredible. Like you're supposed to look after your own trash. So it's just this like culture of cleanliness and taking care of things that's cool. First of all, I think that it might go beyond, I don't want to go too deep on this,
如果你买外带的东西，他们会给你一个小袋子把垃圾装进去，随身带走。哇，太不可思议了。就像你应该照顾好自己的垃圾一样。所以这是一种注重清洁和爱护事物的文化，真的很酷。首先，我觉得这可能不仅仅是……我不想在这上面深入探讨，
but as a Canadian, it goes beyond a little bit just a culture of cleanliness. And it is a culture, there is a thing that is lacking this idea that we have to lift each other up and be responsible to the greater good. I once said to my dad, and I don't know if I've shared this on the show before, I said, why didn't you move to the States?
但作为一个加拿大人，这不仅仅是一点点对清洁文化的追求。这是一种文化，一种缺少这种理念的现象——我们需要互相扶持，对更大的善负起责任。我曾经对父亲说——我不知道我以前是否在节目中分享过这一点——我说：“你为什么不搬去美国？”
When I was younger, I said, he was a lawyer for many years and he went into business. I said, you could have made way more money. He said, because I have an obligation to the States? When I was younger, I said, he was a lawyer for many years and he went into business. I said, you could have made way more money. He said, because I have an obligation to the system that brought me up and he came from nothing. And I don't think that that exists as much in this country. There's much more of a fuck you, I'm getting mine. Which fine, it is the land of opportunity,
我年轻的时候说过，他做了很多年律师后开始经商。我说：“你可以赚更多钱的。”他说：“因为我对培养我的体制负有责任。”他一无所有。我不认为这种精神在这个国家存在得那么多。这里更多的是一种“去你的，我拿我该得的”的心态。好吧，这没问题，这里是机遇之地，
but there is, to answer Sean your question, I think that there is a little bit of that that kind of bleeds into everything. And you look at, you've seen those videos, Pete, I'm sure, of when they decide to rebuild a bridge, a small bridge in the Netherlands on a highway. It's incredible. And they do it in 48 hours
但为了回答肖恩你的问题，我认为这种心态在某种程度上渗透到了所有事情中。你看，皮特，你肯定看过那些视频，当他们决定在荷兰的高速公路上重建一座桥梁、一座小桥时。这太不可思议了。他们在48小时内就完成了，
because they don't want to disrupt the whole system. So everybody, they prep, prep, prep, prep, prep, they shut it down, and they quite literally build the bridge in 48 hours because they don't want to disrupt the whole system. So everybody, they prep, prep, prep, prep, prep, they shut it down and they quite literally build the bridge in 48 hours. That's all hands on deck. No, it's incredible. We worked on ways to emulate that. But I think, I have to agree with you,
因为他们不想扰乱整个系统。所以每个人都做好准备、准备、再准备，然后封锁道路，他们真的在48小时内建好了桥梁，因为他们不想扰乱整个系统。每个人都做好准备、准备、再准备，然后封锁道路，他们真的在48小时内建好了桥梁。那是全员出动。不，这太不可思议了。我们曾致力于寻找效仿这种做法的方法。但我认为，
but I think there's a deeply American tradition around that too. It's always kind of in a bit of a push-pull with the individualistic tradition. But a lot of the great infrastructure we count on, the aviation system, the highways, are built on that spirit. And so is the idea of preparing.
我不得不赞同你的观点，但我也认为周围存在着一种深刻的美国传统。它总是与个人主义传统处于某种拉锯战中。但我们赖以生存的许多伟大基础设施，航空系统、高速公路，都是建立在这种精神之上的。准备工作的理念也是如此。
You know, it was Lincoln who said, give me six hours to chop down a tree and I will spend the first four sharpening my ax. And I think about that a lot because if we apply that to infrastructure, we'd be better off. Hey, I got to ask, speaking of fathers, there's something I've always wanted Jason to ask you about, which is that I once read- I thought you were going to take a shot at Sean.
你知道，林肯曾经说过：“给我六个小时砍倒一棵树，我会把前四个小时用来磨斧头。”我经常想到这一点，因为如果我们把这个理念应用到基础设施上，我们会过得更好。嘿，我得问问，说到父亲，我一直想让杰森问你一件事，那就是我曾经读到过——我以为你要拿肖恩开涮呢。
No, I once read that you are maybe the most prominent Maltese American figure in Hollywood. And I wanted to know, that's the country my dad immigrated from. I'm just kidding. Have you ever been there? Like, do you have a connection to Maltese culture? I went there when I was a little kid. Yeah, actually it's my mother's mother
不，我曾经读到过，你可能是好莱坞最显眼的马耳他裔美国人。我想知道——那是我的父亲移民的国家。我开玩笑呢。你曾去过那里吗？比如，你对马耳他文化有什么联系吗？我小时候去过那里。对，其实是我母亲的母亲
that was from Malta. And that's where she met her husband, my grandfather, because he was in the British Air Force. Classic, yeah, classic thing that happened a lot in that generation. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's a, what an interesting little island out there. Incredibly strategic and rich in history
来自马耳他。就在那里，她遇到了她的丈夫、我的祖父，因为他当时在英国空军服役。经典，是的，那一代人中经常发生的经典故事。对，对，对，对。这是一个，多么有趣的小岛啊。战略地位极其重要，历史底蕴深厚，
and a great filming location, right? The great Popeye was shot there. Yeah, yeah, in fact, I was there, I was with a friend and we stumbled onto the set of World War Z. Oh wow. Because you know, it's a tiny Mediterranean country which means it can be made to look like lots of places,
而且是一个绝佳的拍摄地，对吧？伟大的《大力水手》就是在那里拍摄的。是的，是的，事实上我在那儿，我和一个朋友偶然闯入了《僵尸世界大战》的片场。哦，哇。
especially lots of places in the Middle East or North Africa. I think they used it for Gladiator. But they just changed the signs and they could make, like I think a lot of the scenes in Munich, whether it was in Lebanon or Greece or Israel, Palestine, like a lot of that was shot in Malta. But yeah, World War Z was going on.
因为你知道，这是一个微小的地中海国家，这意味着它可以被伪装成许多地方，特别是中东或北非的许多地方。我想他们拍《角斗士》时也用过这里。但他们只是换了路标，就能让人觉得……我想慕尼黑的很多场景，无论是黎巴嫩、希腊还是以色列、巴勒斯坦，很多都是在马耳他拍的。但是，是的，《僵尸世界大战》当时正在拍摄。
I didn't know what that was, but I was walking with a friend and we just suddenly like the signs on the businesses switched to Hebrew and there was this overturned tank and we had maybe like wandered past the stanchion and didn't notice because they were taking a break. And then this bus pulled up and a bunch of zombies got out. And it's really unnerving. You looked at your drink.
我不知道那是什么，但我正和一个朋友散步，突然我们看到商业区招牌变成了希伯来文，还有一辆翻倒的坦克，我们可能是不小心走过了警戒线却没有注意到，因为当时他们正在休息。接着一辆公共汽车停下来，一群僵尸走了出来。这真的很让人不安。你看了看你的饮料。
You know what was really unnerving was not to see zombies, but to see zombies acting not like zombies, right? I think there were Maltese extras. They were waiting for, you know, for their truck. They were talking casualties. Yeah, there's like a zombie smoking a cigarette. There's a zombie checking his phone. There's a zombie with a bottle of water.
你知道真正让人不安的不是看到僵尸，而是看到僵尸不像僵尸那样行动，对吧？我想那里有马耳他当地的临时演员。他们在等，你知道的，等他们的卡车。他们在谈论伤亡情况。是的，有一个僵尸在抽烟。有一个僵尸在看手机。还有一个僵尸拿着一瓶水。
That was almost more unsettling than seeing a bunch of fewer. They do stop by his pit, walk by, and he just passed out completely. Yeah, he sadly was not present. Have you been there recently? It's been a few years, but I'm hoping soon to be able to take our kids there, because I want to introduce them to,
这甚至比看到一堆凶神恶煞的东西更让人感到不安。他们顺路走过他的地盘，而他完全昏迷不醒。是的，他很遗憾不在场。你最近去过那里吗？已经好几年了，但我希望很快能带我们的孩子们去那儿，因为我想向他们介绍，
I want them to know the one place in the world where their last name is a common name. I want them to meet their cousins and send them. Is that true? Is that a coin to come up? It's like Smith over there. There was a statue to Anton Budajid, who was the president of Malta and a great poet,
我想让他们知道世界上唯一一个他们的姓氏是个常见姓氏的地方。我想让他们去见见他们的表亲，把他们送去。真的吗？这是一个常见的名字？就像那边的“史密斯”一样。那里有一座安东·布加吉奇的雕像，他是马耳他的总统兼伟大诗人，
and we're not even related. That's wild. He was like neighbors with my great grandparents or something like that. I mean, but it's incredible, it's a fascinating place. It's beautiful and interesting. How old are your kids by the way now? They're three, they're turning four this summer. That's great, that's so cool. Boy and a girl, twins.
我们甚至都没亲戚关系。太疯狂了。他就像是我曾祖父母的邻居什么的。我是说，这太不可思议了，这是一个迷人的地方。美丽而有趣。顺便问一下，你的孩子现在多大了？他们三岁了，今年夏天就满四岁了。太棒了，太酷了。一男一女，龙凤胎。
Fun age. That's great. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, I want to get back to infrastructure for one second. You guys got that huge bill passed and got a lot of great stuff started. I'm assuming a lot of that stuff is still happening and marching forward.
好玩的年龄。太棒了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。嘿，我想再回到基础设施的话题上。你们通过了那个巨大的法案，启动了许多伟大的项目。我假设其中很多事情仍在进行中，并在向前推进。
And if the answer to that is yes, is there anything you can talk about that maybe we might not know about that you're super excited about that is still a couple of years away from being completed because a lot of these things are obviously long-term builds but like you said, like bullet train in Tokyo, like stuff like that, what's coming down the road?
如果答案是肯定的，有没有什么事情你可以谈谈，可能是我们可能不知道的、让你超级兴奋的、但距离完工还有好几年的项目？因为其中很多事情显然是长期的建设，但正如你所说，就像东京的子弹头列车一样，接下来会有什么？
Yeah, there's a bus. So we funded about 70,000 projects. Roughly 20,000 of them are done, but yeah, most of them, by their very nature, they take years and years to do. Matter of fact, I drive past one almost every day here in Michigan that I remember signing off on. That's now, actually now everybody's grumbling about it
是的，有公共汽车。所以我们资助了大约70,000个项目。其中大约20,000个已经完成，但是是的，大多数项目就其性质而言，需要耗费大量的时间和精力。事实上，我在密歇根这里几乎每天都会开车经过一个我亲笔签署的项目。现在，其实现在每个人都在抱怨它，
because it's in construction and blocking now, actually now everybody's grumbling about it because it's in construction and blocking traffic. But eventually it's going to be great. There are a few high-speed rail things going on. One I'm excited about is a high-speed rail partnership. We funded it with federal dollars, but there's also a private company bringing a lot of the dollars to the table and partnering with the state of Nevada to get it done. If they hit their marks, it'll be going before the end of this decade and just zip down.
因为它正在施工并且堵塞了道路——其实现在每个人都在抱怨它，因为它正在施工并且堵塞了交通。但最终它会变得非常棒。有一些高铁项目正在进行中。让我兴奋的一个项目是高铁合伙企业。我们用联邦资金资助了它，但同时也有私营公司投入大量资金，并与内华达州合作来完成它。如果他们达到目标，它将在本十年结束前投入运营，并飞速驰骋。
A lot of it is actually straight down the median of I-15. That's how they solved the puzzle of getting the... Because one of the hardest things when you're building a railroad is to put together the right of way, right? To get the land lined up. And so there was a big portion where they were able to take advantage of the right of way that's already there on the interstate. So that's one that I'm excited about.
其中很大一部分其实是直接沿着15号州际公路的中分带修建的。这就是他们解决获取……难题的方法，因为修建铁路最难的事情之一就是拼凑出路权，对吧？要把土地连成一线。所以在很大程度上，他们能够利用高速公路上现有的路权。所以这是让我兴奋的一个项目。
How long would that take, do you think, to get from Vegas to LA? I know it's dramatically quicker than driving. I think I got to look it up, but definitely under the, because it's hours and hours. I like the idea of the train of like, going to Vegas, that train is filled with happy, excited people and coming back, it's all somber and hungover.
你认为从拉斯维加斯到洛杉矶需要多长时间？我知道这比开车快得多。我想我得查一下，但绝对在……因为开车要好几个小时。我挺喜欢坐火车的概念，去拉斯维加斯时，火车上坐满了快乐、兴奋的人，而回来时，所有人都沮丧而宿醉。
Yeah, you'd rather walk home. Everybody's broke. Totally. No, what excites me is the idea that like, instead of going to Japan and coming back and talking about how amazing it would be, to have something like that, like we'd see that somewhere in the US. Because I think if people experience that
对，你宁愿走着回家。每个人都破产了。完全是这样。不，让我兴奋的是这样一种想法：与其去日本回来后谈论它是多么不可思议，不如在美國某处也能看到这样的东西。因为我认为如果人们在美国某处体验到这一点，那么人们就会到处都想要它。而且，你知道，是的，我正在查。他们正朝着2小时10分钟的目标努力。
somewhere in the US, then people are going to want it everywhere. And it's, you know, it's, yeah, I'm looking it up now. It's two hours and 10 minutes is what they're shooting for. Gotcha. Oh wow, that's pretty good. Did you push forward stuff that we can expect to see a bunch of cars driving around without drivers behind it or trucks without drivers? Is that stuff coming as well? to see a bunch of cars driving around without drivers behind it, or trucks without drivers?
明白了。哦，哇，那相当不错。你们有没有推动那些我们可以期待看到的、周围跑着许多没有司机在后面开的车或没有司机的卡车的事情？这些事情也即将来临吗？
Is that stuff coming as well? So yeah, we worked on that. We don't, the industry is creating that. That's the private sector. But our job was to kind of work on the policies to make sure it was safe and to try to support some of the pilot programs that were going on. I actually really believe in the potential
所以，是的，我们在这方面做过工作。我们不……是行业在创造这些。那是私营部门。但我们的工作是制定政策，确保其安全性，并尝试支持一些正在进行的试点项目。我其实真的很相信这项技术的潜力。
of this technology. I know it's spooky for people. You see a car, there's nobody behind the wheel. It's definitely. But as you mentioned earlier about distracted drivers, that takes the main cause of danger out of it. Exactly, no, it's definitely possible to envision a future where people are shocked that we drove our own cars.
我知道这让人感到有些毛骨悚然。你看到一辆车，方向盘后面没有人。这绝对是……但正如你之前提到的分心驾驶，它消除了导致危险的主要原因。没错，不，完全可以想象这样一个未来：人们会为我们曾经自己开车而感到震惊。
Yeah. Right. But I have to say though, because I just, actually I was just talking to you, Jay and Will, at dinner the other day. Yeah, Waymo, right? Yeah, I was talking about Waymo, which is a self-driving cars. Yeah. Right. But I have to say though, because I just, actually I was just talking to you, Jay and Will, at dinner the other day. Yeah, Waymo, right? Yeah, I was talking about Waymo, which is a self-driving car, and I've been in one before, but I'm like, of course I'm a catastrophic thinker, so I think of all the bad parts
是的。对的。但我必须说，因为我刚——其实我前几天才在晚饭时和你、杰伊和威尔谈过这件事。是的，Waymo，对吧？是的，我当时在谈论Waymo，也就是自动驾驶汽车。是的。对的。但我必须说，因为我刚——其实我前几天才在晚饭时和你、杰伊和威尔谈过这件事。是的，Waymo，对吧？是的，我当时在谈论Waymo，这是一种自动驾驶汽车，我以前坐过，但我觉得，当然我是一个灾难论者，所以我想到了所有的坏处，
and all the bad things that could happen. So I'm like, well, this is a terrorist's dream to have, I mean, there's so many scenarios I could come up with, I could tell you right now, about how to use self-driving cars in a horrible way. Well, just one, give us one. Well, maybe you'd be late for a daytime massage. Start there.
以及所有可能发生的糟糕事情。所以我想，嗯，对恐怖分子来说，这简直是个梦想，我是说，我能想出很多场景，我现在就能告诉你，如何以一种可怕的方式使用自动驾驶汽车。好吧，哪怕举一个例子。好吧，也许你白天按摩会迟到。从这开始想象吧。
Imagine that. It wouldn't have, it didn't need to know to put the key in the cup holder. Yeah. No, Pete, how many billions did you guys put towards? Yeah, no, that's the kill switch You take you take the key out of the cup holder and then you don't have a problem Yeah, no you but my thing is Sean as I said to you is like I'm worried about cars showing up
想象一下。它不需要知道把钥匙放进杯托里。是的。不，皮特，你们投入了多少十亿……对，不，那是紧急切断开关。你把钥匙从杯托里拿出来，然后你就没有问题了。是的，不，你……但我的意思是，肖恩，正如我对你所说的那样，我担心的是汽车开到餐厅时，
Restaurants with people who have reservations and it shows up a valet is just like a dead person in the back You know what I mean? Yeah, that's a hard attack on their way to do or that. Yeah or that well, I will admit I never thought do it. Yeah, or that, yeah, or that. Well, I will admit I never thought of that. Yeah. I was thinking about it. I could think about it. You know what I mean? And then all of a sudden.
车里坐着有预约的人，结果车一到，代客泊车发现后座上是个死人，你知道我的意思吗？是的，那在他们去办事的路上心脏病发作了，或者类似的情况。是的，或者那个，或者那……好吧，我承认我从没想过那个。是的。我在想这个。我能想到这个。你知道我的意思吗？然后突然之间。
So Pete, you've got such a, you seem to treasure like we all do our private life. And I would assume that your incredibly accomplished career in public life has made that difficult to maintain. Was that a part, as we all try to battle with it, is that a part that you are comfortable maintaining? Do you guys, do you find the ability to be private
所以皮特，你拥有如此……你似乎和我们所有人一样珍视你的私生活。我想你在公众生活中取得的巨大成就使得这一点很难维持。这是否是——在我们都在与之斗争的同时——你觉得能够自如维持的一部分？你们，你们觉得能保有私密空间吗，
or are you guys, because you must get stopped all the time on the street and is that tough for the kids? Yeah, I definitely think about it differently. It's one thing to take a selfie with somebody at the airport or at a restaurant when I'm just doing my thing. It's another if I feel like somebody might be
还是说你们——因为你在街上肯定总是被人认出来，这对孩子们来说是不是很艰难？是的，我对这个问题的看法确实有所不同。在机场或餐馆里，当我只是在做自己的事情时，和某人拍张自拍照是一回事。但如果我觉得有人可能在
taking pictures of our kids or we're just trying to. Pretending to be reading an email. Yeah, I mean, I'm sure you've had this experience where people go through all kinds of links to look like they're not taking a picture when they're taking a picture. I'm usually pretty oblivious to this. Chastain detects it and then usually takes a picture
偷拍我们的孩子，或者我们只是想……假装在看电子邮件。是的，我是说，我确信你也有过这种经历，人们会想方设法地假装没有在拍照，其实他们正在拍照。我通常对这些事情相当迟钝。查斯汀能察觉到，然后通常会回拍他们一张，或者拿这逗逗他们。但就像，你知道的，直接要求合影就行了。或者会大声说：“你拍到了吗？”
back at them or teases them about it. But it's like, you know, just ask for a picture. Or says like, I do real loud, did you get it? Ask for a picture, it's fine. But yeah, obviously you think about those things differently with your kids. but I'll say like, the community we're in in Michigan is really great, really warm, welcoming, supportive.
要求合影，这没问题。但是，是的，有了孩子后，你显然会对这些事情有不同的看法。但我得说，我们在密歇根所在的社区真的很好，非常热情、友好、支持我们。而且他们知道你在那儿，所以是的。
And they know you're there, so yeah. And generally, when we're out and about, I mean, people understand that we have a family, but yeah, you think about this differently. You know, there are three, so they're not old enough to really notice or care about, you know, stuff that goes with being high profile right now, but it, yeah, it definitely changes the stakes, to really notice or care about stuff that goes with being high profile right now.
通常情况下，当我们外出时，人们理解我们有家庭，但是是的，你对这件事的看法不同了。你知道，他们才三岁，所以还没到那种真正会注意到或在意高调生活所带来的种种事情的年纪，但它，是的，它绝对改变了赌注——还没到真正会注意到或在意高调生活所带来的种种事情的年纪。
But it definitely changes the stakes, I think, for anyone who's in public life and is thinking about what to do next. Right. Go ahead, John. I was just saying, have you ever heard of a place called Galeen, Michigan? Yeah, yeah. It's a really small town.
但它绝对改变了赌注，我认为，对于任何身处公众生活并考虑下一步行动的人来说都是如此。没错。说吧，约翰。我只是想说，你听说过一个叫加林（Galeen）的密歇根小镇吗？是的，是的。那是个很小的镇。
It's not too far from South Bend, I think. Okay, so it's- You got a timeshare you want to offer? No, Reyna, one of my best friends- Reyna lives there. Reyna lives, she has a restaurant there called Ray and Al's, and it's. You got a timeshare you want to offer them? No, Reyna, my best friend. Reyna lives there. Reyna lives, she has a restaurant there called Rey and Al's and it's one of the greatest restaurants so you check it out. Oh good to know.
我想离南本德不远。好吧，所以——你有分时度假房想出租吗？不，雷娜，我最好的朋友之一——雷娜住在那里。雷娜住，她在那里开了一家餐馆叫雷与阿尔（Ray and Al's），那是……你有分时度假房想出租给他们吗？不，雷娜，我最好的朋友。雷娜住在那里。雷娜住，她在那里开了一家餐馆叫雷与阿尔，那是最好的餐馆之一，所以你应该去看看。哦，很高兴知道。
Alright. Thank you caller. Thank you. Good plug for Reyna, for Rey and Al's. Well no, I didn't know if you. It was close there. Shawn what's the name of the town? Their website you want to.
好的。谢谢来电者。谢谢。为雷娜、为雷与阿尔做个好广告。好吧，不，我不知道你知不知道。那里很近。肖恩，那个镇叫什么名字？他们的网站你想……
Galeen, Galeen. Galeen, if you're in Galeen, Michigan, go Ray and Al's and say, Rayna, and say hi, say, Sean sent you. And you get 10% off your appetizers. Exactly, exactly. So listen, you don't have to answer this, but I would love if you ran for president. And then second, is there something,
加林，加林。加林，如果你在密歇根州的加林，去雷与阿尔，找雷娜，打个招呼，说“是肖恩让你来的”。你就能在开胃菜上享受九折优惠。没错，没错。所以听着，你不需要回答这个问题，但我很希望你能竞选总统。其次，有没有什么事情——
because Jason kind of asked what your, well, what are you worried about the most in the future, in the near future, and what are you most hopeful about? Well, obviously, like, politically, I think my worries about the political scene here are, I imagine, pretty obvious. I'm concerned about the things that are happening to freedom in this country,
因为杰森刚才问了你的，嗯，你对未来的近未来最担心的是什么，你最抱有希望的是什么？嗯，显然，在政治上，我对这里政治局面的担忧，我想大家都是显而易见的。我担心这个国家的自由正在发生的事情，我对此直言不讳。我也非常担心人工智能可能会带来的后果，我指的不仅仅是灭绝情景和所有那些疯狂的事情。我说的是离我们更近一些、而且我认为比人们意识到的更快的危机，
and I've been very outspoken about that. I'm also very concerned about what could happen with AI, and I don't just mean like the extinction scenarios and all the crazy stuff. I'm talking about something a little closer to home, and I think quicker than people realize, which is how many jobs are at risk. Stuff that we thought would happen in like 100 years,
那就是有多少工作岗位正处于危险之中。我们原本以为要100年才会发生的事情，可能在本十年结束前就会发生，并且会极其深刻地改变一切。皮特，我们前几天还在讨论这件事，因为我们在讨论将制造业带回美国的想法——我们都同意这太棒了，对吧？如果我们能创造更多的工作岗位，那些几十年来失去的工作岗位。
and it could happen by the end of this decade, and just really, really profoundly changing everything. Pete, we were having a discussion about this the other day because we were talking about the idea of bringing manufacturing back to the US, which we all could agree would be fantastic, right? If we could create more jobs, jobs that were lost over decades and decades.
而且很多，顺便说一句，其中很多工作岗位是被那些说“天哪，我们是怎么搞成这样的？”的同一个人外包并送到国外的。好吧，不是我们干的，是你们干的，因为这给你们省了很多钱。然而，我们都可以同意，带回更多工作岗位将是太棒了。这毫无争议。
And a lot by, and by the way, a lot of those jobs were farmed out and sent over there by the very same people who were saying, hey, what the hell? How did we do this? Well, we didn't do it. You guys did it because it was saving you a lot of money. However, we can all agree it would be fantastic to bring more jobs. There's no argument there.
但我们前几天晚上讨论的事情之一是现在这种想法——你提到了人工智能，当它与机器人技术的进步相结合时，我们有可能在这个国家的相当大规模上真正摧毁劳动力市场，正如你所指出的，速度相当快。是的，不仅是制造业工人或仓库工人，我们还在谈论医生、律师、投资者，就像是，你知道的。
But one of the things we were talking about the other night is this idea that now, and you brought it up, AI, when you combine that with advancement in robotics, we have the potential to really decimate the workforce here in this country on a pretty massive scale, and as you pointed out, quite quickly. Yeah, and not just manufacturing workers or warehouse workers, we're talking about doctors, lawyers, investors, like it's, you know.
是的，所有这些。我是说，好莱坞就是这一切的暴风眼，编剧罢工就证明了受到影响的人群范围有多广。但这让我想到了希望的一面，那就是我认为如果我们处理得当，这里同样蕴藏着巨大的潜力。但是，我们的政治必须走上正轨，我们的经济也必须走上正轨。
Yes, all of it. I mean, Hollywood was ground zero for some of this, right, with the writer's strike, and that shows just how big a range of people are impacted. But that brings me to maybe the hope side, which is I think if we get it right, there's also enormous potential here. But like, our politics has to be lined up the right way, and we have to line up our economy the right way.
我的意思是，以自动驾驶汽车为例，对吧？这里有各种各样的噩梦般的场景。但这也是一个消除该国主要死因的机会，那就是人类司机那种骇人的安全记录。我们每年因此失去40,000人的生命。
And what I mean by that, I mean, take the example of self-driving cars, right? There's all kinds of nightmare scenarios. There's also a chance to eliminate one of the leading causes of death in this country, which is the kind of murderous track record of human drivers. We lose 40,000 people a year.
更广泛地说，就像可能带来巨大混乱的同一套人工智能系统，也能帮助我们治愈癌症、解决气候变化以及所有这些其他问题。我认为最大的问题是：我们是否拥有一个政治系统，能够确保这项技术创造的巨额财富流向人民，还是会被集中起来？哦，我们当然有，皮特。
And more generally, like the same AI systems that could cause huge disruption could also help us cure cancer and solve climate change and all these other things. I think the biggest question is do we have a political system that makes sure that the enormous wealth that's being created by this technology flows through to the people or does it get concentrated? Oh, for sure we do, Pete.
我一点也不担心这个。很高兴你不用担心。不，不，不，不。我真的很期待，你们对《威尔和格蕾丝》的机器人人工智能新版本兴奋吗？那会有多棒？嘿，大家好，我是杰克。是我，我只是杰克。
I'm not worried about that at all. I'm glad you're not worried. No, no, no, no. I'm really excited about, are you guys excited about the new robotic AI version of Will and Grace? How good would that be? Hey, everybody, it's just Jack. It's me, it's just Jack.
我们已经看过了。但是皮特，当你说的财富“流回人民手中”时，会是培训失业劳动力以更好地过渡到通过技术进步获得的新工作的形式吗？我其实指的是金钱，比如分红。因为请记住，纳税人创造了很大一部分价值。就像互联网在60年代字面意义上就是一个联邦研究项目，是由美国纳税人资助的。
We already saw it. But Pete, when you say flowing back through the people, would that be in the shape of perhaps training the workforce that would be without a job to better transition into a job that is available, maybe through the advancements? I just mean money, actually, like a dividend. Because remember, the taxpayer created a lot of this value. Like the internet was literally a federal research project in the 60s, funded by the American taxpayers.
我们已经看到了。但是皮特，当你说的通过人民回流时，这是否会表现为对失业劳动力进行培训，以更好地过渡到由于技术进步而出现的新岗位？我其实指的就是钱，比如红利。因为记住，纳税人创造了这其中的大量价值。就像互联网在20世纪60年代字面上就是一个联邦研究项目，是由美国纳税人资助的。
So to me, it's only fair that Americans see more of the income generated by it. But also the thing with training is this isn't just about getting people their income back. I've seen this where I come from in the industrial Midwest. Somebody's been working in a machine shop for 18 years. And then that machine shop is closing down and they come along and say,
所以对我来说，美国人能从中获得更多收入才算公平。但培训的问题在于，这不仅仅是让人们恢复收入。我在我老家工业中西部就见过这种情况。有人在机械厂工作了18年。然后机械厂要倒闭了，他们走过来对你说，
well, do this retraining program, same education, you'll get the same income, you just gotta be a nurse's aide. And that's a perfectly worthy job, but this guy does not, that job wasn't just his income, that was his identity. And if you're not speaking to that, then we're gonna have all kinds of social upheaval,
嗯，去参加这个再培训项目吧，学历要求一样，收入也一样，你只需改行去当护士助理就行。这完全是一份值得尊敬的工作，但这个人……那份工作不仅仅是他的收入，那是他的身份认同。如果你没有说到点子上，那我们就会面临各种社会动荡，
as we already are, but it's gonna get worse. So then what would be the answer then, getting back to your point about maybe training for transitioning into another available occupation, if that occupation is not aligned with somebody's passion or dreams or identity, what would the answer then be to how to use the newfound funds? Well, I think, and again, I think some of the funds
就像我们现在已经经历的那样，而且情况还会恶化。那么，答案到底是什么呢？回到你刚才的观点，关于为转型到其他可用职业进行培训，如果这个职业并不符合某人的热情、梦想或身份认同，那么对于如何使用这些新获得的资金，答案又会是什么呢？嗯，我认为，再次强调，我认为部分资金
should just directly, we should have a tax structure where those funds are directly flowing to people more. But in terms of what we do, I think we as a society don't know what to do with ourselves sometimes if we're not putting it all into our jobs. And I'm somebody, you know, I'm guilty of that. Like I have meaningful work and I've thrown myself into my jobs.
应该直接发给民众，我们应该建立一种税收结构，让这些资金更直接地流向人们。但就我们的做法而言，我认为如果我们不把全部精力投入到工作中，我们有时作为社会的一员，就不知道该拿自己怎么办。我本人，你知道的，我也难辞其咎。我有很有意义的工作，我也全身心地投入到了工作中。
And that can be a very good thing. But there's so many other sources of meaning that can be connected to service. They can be connected to a lot of things that used to be considered maybe more conservative coded, but I think my party should pay more attention to them, like family and faith that can bring meaning to a lot of people.
这当然是一件非常好的事。但还有那么多其他意义的源泉，它们可以与服务联系在一起。它们可以与许多曾经被认为带有更多保守色彩的事物联系在一起，但我认为我的政党应该对它们给予更多关注，比如家庭和信仰，这些能给许多人带来意义。
Local involvement, like shaping your community, like things where uniquely human skills are absolutely needed, that we could show more regard for. Like as an economy and a society, we don't show a lot of regard for the work that goes into parenting. We definitely don't compensate that kind of work properly. Same thing with service.
比如参与社区活动、塑造你的社区，在这些绝对需要人类独有技能的领域，我们可以给予更多尊重。作为一个经济体和社会，我们并不十分尊重育儿工作。我们绝对没有恰当地补偿这种工作。服务也是如此。
I mean, right now they're cutting AmeriCorps as we record this. They're cutting all kinds of service things that actually in a world where AI generates more the value and productivity, like we could, you know, a lot of people could have a shorter work week, more money in their pockets, and a chance to do things in their community
我是说，就在我们录音的这个时候，他们正在削减“美国国民服务队”（AmeriCorps）的经费。他们在削减各种服务项目的经费，而实际上，在一个由人工智能创造更多价值和生产力的世界里，你知道的，很多人本可以拥有更短的工作周、更多的可支配收入，以及为社区做一些事情的机会，
that would absolutely be a source of pride and meaning. And I want to live in that kind of society. Well, Pete, I made that, and I was quite flippant about it when I made the comparison to Canada and the US in terms of a sense of social consciousness. But because I do agree with you, I do agree that there is a long history of it
那绝对会成为自豪感和意义的来源。我想生活在那样的一个社会里。好吧，皮特，我刚才那么说了，当我把加拿大和美国在社会意识感方面进行对比时，我表现得挺轻率的。但因为我确实同意你的观点，我确实认为这个国家有着悠久的历史，
in this country and that there is still a vein of that. I think that we've been maybe potentially distracted is the word that I'll use and maybe in certain areas gotten off the path and focused more on our differences and also focused more on ourselves. But I think you're right. I think that if potentially we can all start and I mean all of us, I mean me too, if we can all start thinking about somebody we're so hung up on our own condition. And if we could start thinking about somebody, we're so hung up on our own condition. And if we could start thinking about other people, it's a really simple concept that
并且这种脉络依然存在。我想我们可能被分心了，这是我能想到的词，也许在某些领域偏离了轨道，更多地关注我们的分歧，也更多地关注我们自己。但我想你是对的。我想，如果我们所有人都能开始——我是指我们所有人，也包括我——如果我们所有人都能开始考虑别人……我们太纠结于自身的境况了。如果我们能开始考虑别人……这是一个非常简单的概念，
if you think about somebody else and you think about helping somebody else, your actual situation improves immediately. Well, it does, your own situation does improve because it changes your vibration to sound like woo woo. I totally agree with all that. Absolutely true. And being of service is super, super important. And if everybody did it a little bit,
如果你去为别人着想，去考虑如何帮助别人，你的实际处境就会立刻得到改善。嗯，确实会，你自己的处境确实会改善，因为它改变了你的磁场——听起来有点像玄学（woo woo）。我完全同意所有这些。绝对正确。而且能够服务他人超级、超级重要。如果每个人都稍微做一点，
the shift would be absolutely. I know, but how do you get people to do it? I don't know. Put a little incentive there. Yeah, I mean, if you boil it down, if you're feeling bad, just on a day to day, if you wake up today, if I feel bad today, if I go out and do something for somebody else, I will immediately alleviate that
这种转变将是绝对的。我知道，但你怎么让人们去做呢？我不知道。加一点激励机制呗。对啊，我是说，归根结底，如果你感觉不好，只是日常生活中，如果你今天醒来，如果我今天感觉不好，如果我出去为别人做点什么，我会立刻缓解这种情绪，
and raise my own vibration. Again, it sounds very woo-woo. I'm not woo-woo that way. Well, is it something that you're tracking on your aura ring on the app itself? Yeah. Jason, this concept is tougher. Doing something for somebody else, how would I,
并提升我自己的磁场。再说一次，这听觉上很玄学。我可不是那种玄学的人。好吧，这是你在“指环”（Oura Ring）应用上追踪的数据吗？对啊。杰森，这个概念更难理解。为别人做点什么，我该怎么……
let me look at it. Yeah, you talk slower, please. Do pictures, pictures are better, pictures are better. Pete, before we let you go, I would love to hear from you who, if you could travel back in time, who would you love to sit down, have a coffee with, to get some tips from on how to address this, I would, I guess I shouldn't say uniquely
让我看看。对，请你说慢一点。拍照片，照片更好，照片更好。皮特，在我们让你离开之前，我很想听听看，如果你能回到过去，你最想和谁坐下来喝杯咖啡，向他们请教如何应对——我想我不应该说这是一个独一无二的
challenging situation where we find ourselves in, because we seem to cycle through moments like this, I guess I shouldn't say uniquely challenging situation where we find ourselves in, because we seem to cycle through moments like this, but who'd you love to talk to right now? Well, I can definitely imagine, and I was maybe a little obvious to the point of cliche, but I can picture like, if I get to have a coffee with Abraham Lincoln, and I'm saying like, look, our country's divided,
具有挑战性的局面，我们发现自己正身处其中，因为我们似乎在不断经历这样的时刻，我想我不应该说我们发现自己身处一个独一无二的挑战性局面，因为我们似乎在经历这样的时刻，但你现在最想和谁交谈？嗯，我绝对能想象到，虽然这可能明显得近乎陈词滥调，但我可以想象，如果我能和亚伯拉罕·林肯喝杯咖啡，我会对他说：“看吧，我们的国家分裂了，”
it's probably, he says, oh, you think your country's divided? Wow, okay. I mean, he was in charge when half of the country broke off and declared war against the other half, mainly for the purpose of being able to continue enslaving people, right? So for a little perspective around our problems, I think he would be a really good person to talk to.
他可能会说：“哦，你觉得你们国家分裂了？哇，好吧。”我的意思是，当国家一半地区分裂并向另一半宣战时，他正掌舵呢，而宣战的主要目的居然是为了能够继续奴役人民，对吧？所以，为了让我们对自己的问题有一个更宏观的视角，我认为他是一个非常适合交谈的人。
And also somebody who was unflappable in so many ways. And for somebody who was unflappable in so many ways. And like for somebody who has the ambition to become a president and a wartime president, surprisingly low ego. There's a famous anecdote where one of his generals was getting out of hand and his advisor said, you got to cut this guy down to size. And he said, I would hold his horse
而且他在很多方面都是一个泰然自若的人。在很多方面都是一个泰然自若的人。而且，对于一个有着总统雄心、并且在战时担任总统的人来说，他的自我（ego）却出奇地低。有一个著名的轶事，当时他的一位将军有些失控，他的顾问说：“你得把这家伙的气焰压下去。”他说：“只要他能为我赢得这场战役，
if he could win this battle for me. And just attributes that I would like to see a little more of. So I know it's a little obvious, but I can't think of, like in the political space, I can't think of somebody you'd more want to consult than Lincoln. No, it's a good answer.
我甚至愿意帮他牵马。”这些品质是我希望看到更多人具备的。所以我知道这有点显而易见，但在政治领域，我想不出还有谁比林肯更值得你去请教。不，这是个好答案。
And I had asked Sean about a week ago that same question. You know what he said he'd like to sit down? Chef Boyardee. What? Yeah. Really? Just to see, you just said a nice meal. It's just.
我大约一周前问过肖恩同样的问题。你知道他说他想和谁坐下来吗？“博亚迪大厨”（Chef Boyardee）。什么？对啊。真的吗？就是为了看一眼……你只是说想吃顿好饭。就是……
Yeah, just how did it come out so well. Yeah, I would get heart. How did you add? Number two, the Colonel. Yeah. Number two, the Colonel. Yeah, so how do you make it? And then Ronald McDonald.
对啊，怎么就能做得那么好呢。对啊，我会生气的。你是怎么加的？第二位，山德士上校（The Colonel）。对。第二位，山德士上校。对，那你是怎么做的？然后是麦当劳叔叔。
So listen. Hey. Pete, thank you so, so much for coming on and making us. Yes, don't ever stop talking and going on these shows. I mean, it's just. Please. Yeah. You're just amazing and thank you so, so much for coming on and making us. Don't ever stop talking and going on these shows. I mean, it's just, you're just amazing and thank you for all that you do. Hey, thanks for having me. I really enjoyed it.
所以听着。嘿。皮特，非常非常感谢你来参加节目，让我们……没错，千万别停止说话，也别停止上这些节目。我的意思是，这简直……拜托。对啊。你太棒了，非常非常感谢你来参加节目，让我们……千万别停止说话，也别停止上这些节目。我的意思是，这简直……你太棒了，谢谢你所做的一切。嘿，谢谢邀请我。我真的很享受。
Yeah, yeah. All right, looking forward to seeing more of you in the very near future, if you know what I mean. I'll be around. I'll be out there. Thank you. I'll be around. See you later.
对，对。好的，期待在不久的将来能更多地看到你，如果你懂我的意思的话。我会在这附近的。我会出去的。谢谢。我会在这附近的。回头见。
Thank you very much. Thank you so much. Love to you and Chastin and the kids too. Yes. Thanks so much. Okay, good, all right. I'll be around. See you later, thank you very much. See you, thank you so much. Love to you and Chastain and the kids too. Yes. Thanks so much. Okay, bye. Bye. Take care. There, yeah, I felt weird calling him Pete. I know, me too.
非常感谢。非常感谢。代我向查斯顿（Chastain）和孩子们问好。好的。非常感谢。好的，很好，行。我会在这附近的。回头见，非常感谢。再见，非常感谢。代我向查斯顿和孩子们问好。好的。非常感谢。好的，拜拜。拜拜。保重。那个，对，叫他皮特感觉怪怪的。我知道，我也是。
I feel like that was a... Who started calling him Pete? I think I did. I'm sorry. It kind of, it came out by accident and I felt like that was maybe disrespectful, but... No, it wasn't. I don't think he would have minded.
我觉得那是个……是谁开始叫他皮特的？我想是我。对不起。这有点……是不小心脱口而出的，我觉得这可能有点不尊重，但是……不，不是的。我觉得他不会介意的。
I have had a dinner with him a couple times. Secretary Buttigieg, is that what we should have said? Mr. Secretary? Mr. Secretary. Well, but he's not that anymore. But I think you get to carry that forever. Oh, you do, okay. I don't know.
我和他吃过好几次饭。布蒂吉格部长，这才是我们该称呼的？部长先生？部长先生。嗯，但他现在已经不是了。但我觉得这个头衔你可以终身拥有。哦，是吗，好吧。我不知道。
Yeah, as a coach. Sean, will you write him something nice and apologize for us? Yeah, apologize for us. Just say that you had started it and you feel bad that the other guys. Could you mail it with some hazardous materials just to test his theory out?
对啊，作为教练。肖恩，你能给他写点好听的话并替我们道个歉吗？对，替我们道个歉。就说这是你先叫的，而且你为其他伙计们感到难过……你能不能在信里夹点危险品，顺便测试一下他的理论？
Just to test his theory. By the way, I didn't want to say anything, but I put my hand in my pocket during that interview and I still have two peanut M&Ms in it. Oh my, what from last night's rave? No, tonight, this morning I put them in there. Because you was waiting. Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on.
顺便测试一下他的理论。顺便说一句，我本来不想说什么，但在采访时我把手放进口袋里，里面居然还有两颗花生M&M巧克力豆。天哪，是昨晚狂欢节剩下的吗？不，是今晚，今早我放进去的。因为你在等……等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下。
It's 10.30 in the morning. You put two peanut M&Ms in before 9.30? Yeah. Well, just in case you were thinking, well maybe I can earn these at some point today. Yeah. No, I had a bunch of them and I ate them all, but I thought I had them all and there's two left in there.
现在是早上10点30分。你在9点30分之前就放了两颗花生M&M进去了？对啊。好吧，以防你在想，也许我今天某个时候能赚到这些豆子。对啊。不，我有一大包，我都吃光了，但我以为我都吃完了，结果里面还剩两颗。
What time did you have your first M&M today? Nine, nine, like a little after nine. What's the matter with you? Did that come out of the candy ball there in the living room? Yes, you know it very well. You know you won't eat them if you don't have a candy ball. Wait, can you write that down? Yeah.
你今天几点吃的第一颗M&M？九点，九点，九点过一点。你这人怎么回事？那是从客厅的糖果碗里拿出来的吗？是的，你太清楚了。你知道如果没有糖果碗，你根本不会吃它们。等等，你能把这个记下来吗？对。
How often do you go to the dentist? I just went yesterday. And? Everything's great. It's not like I don't brush. I don't eat candy and then close my mouth. Do you floss? Yeah, every day. Truly? I do every single brush. I don't eat candy and then close my mouth. Do you floss? Yeah, every day.
你多久去看一次牙医？我昨天刚去过。然后呢？一切都很好。并不是说我不刷牙。我不会吃完糖果就把嘴闭上。你用牙线吗？对，每天都用。真的吗？我每次刷牙都用。我不会吃完糖果就把嘴闭上。你用牙线吗？对，每天都用。
Truly? I do every single day. Why wouldn't? And that's morning or night? I do morning and if I ate something, like a steak or something that gets between your teeth, I do like, I'll do another floss, I'll do a second floss. And you do the little swords
真的吗？我每天都用。怎么会不用？那是早上还是晚上？我早晚都用，如果我吃了什么东西，比如牛排之类的会卡在牙缝里的东西，我就会……我还会再用一次牙线，我会用第二次牙线。你用那种小牙线棒，
or do you do the old school? No, I can't do the swords because they make your gums bleed because you put them down so hard. You know what I mean? Well, once you be nicer to yourself and you won't bleed. You know, go softer. But you don't have a choice because you gotta get it in there.
还是用老式的牙线？不，我不能用牙线棒，因为它们会让你的牙龈出血，因为你下手太狠了，你知道我的意思吗？好吧，一旦你对自己温柔一点，就不会出血了。你知道的，下手轻点。但你没得选，因为你必须把它塞进去。
They're not as good as actual floss either. That's right. They're good in a pinch. You can control the floss, you know. Yeah, but they're a cheat and they're not as good and it makes you a lesser person. Weren't we just talking about the Secretary of Transportation, Pete Buttigieg,
它们也没真正的牙线好用。没错。应急的时候挺好。你可以控制牙线，你知道的。对，但它们是作弊，没那么好用，而且会让你显得低人一等。我们刚才不是在谈交通部长皮特·布蒂吉格吗，
and now I brought us into floss, I apologize. How great is he? By the way, you both asked all the questions I would have wanted to ask, and I didn't, he didn't answer the thing about the president. I mean, do you think he'll run? Well, I think- Well, you didn't ask him.
现在我把话题扯到了牙线上面，我道歉。他有多棒？顺便说一句，你们俩问了所有我想问的问题，而且我没问……他没有回答关于总统的问题。我是说，你觉得他会参选吗？嗯，我觉得……嗯，你没问他。
You said I want you to. On purpose, I know. We didn't want to ambush him with that. That's right. It's too early, and you know. That's right, I just kind of glazed over it, but I wonder. You didn't ask him for any theater stories. I, you didn't ask him for any theater stories.
你说过我想让你问的。我是故意没问的，我知道。我们不想用那个搞突袭。没错。现在还太早，你知道的。没错，我只是草草带过了，不过我在想。你没问他任何关于戏剧界的故事。我……你没问他任何戏剧界的故事。
I didn't ask him for any. You know what I liked about him? He speaks very soberly, and I do like the idea that he goes on to other shows, he goes on to shows across the political spectrum, and I think that's really important, because as you both know, we all have, we have a lot of people in our lives,
我什么都没问。你知道我喜欢他哪一点吗？他说话非常稳重，而且我确实很喜欢他去参加其他节目、去参加跨越整个政治光谱的节目的这种做法，我觉得这非常重要，因为正如你们俩都知道的，我们所有人都有，我们生活中有很多人，
friends and family who live across that same political spectrum. And we all find ways to meet in the middle and talk about stuff and we all want the best for each other and I like the idea that he goes and he does that very same thing. I don't feel as divided as a lot of people do from the people on other ends of the spectrum.
朋友和家人都分布在那个政治光谱的不同角落。我们都在寻找方法在中间相遇，谈论事情，我们都希望彼此能有最好的结果，我喜欢他去践行这种完全相同的做法。比起很多人，我对光谱另一端的人并没有感到那么强烈的对立。
I think it's important that we all continue to talk because we're all in this together. That's right. Yes, amen. Amen. And he checks a lot of boxes that you think would piece both sides. Yeah.
我认为我们所有人继续对话很重要，因为我们都在同一条船上。没错。是的，阿门。阿门。而且他符合很多你认为能让双方都满意的标准。对。
I agree. And there are a lot of things that make sense that a lot of people say, you know, and there's some, sometimes the message is harder for people to digest and I get, or not the message, the delivery and the approach, but you know, we do have a lot of stuff that's common ground. And JB, I know you're looking for a body. He has a nice way about him.
我同意。有很多事情是合乎情理的，许多人都这么说，你知道的，而且有时有些信息对人们来说很难消化，我理解，或者说不是信息本身难消化，而是传达的方式和方法，但你知道，我们确实有很多共同点。而且JB，我知道你在找一个生物（body）。他为人很好。
He does have a really nice way about him. Nice way about him. Yeah, he does. He's got a very nice speaking voice on him. Yeah, he does. And I meant it when he says he takes the contention out of it, right? He's like, I'm not here to argue.
他为人确实真的很好。为人很好。对，他确实很好。他说话的声音非常好听。对，确实好听。我没说错，他说他消除了争论性，对吧？他就好像在说，我不是来吵架的，
I'm just here to talk and let's all feel like we're getting, Sean's thinking of a, one of you's thinking of a biome. I'm doing Google search right now. You know what, I think up a lot of them in between, like during the week and then I forget them. That's a good story. You should open with that. You know what, a bison I heard would be a good one to work in.
我只是来谈谈，让我们都觉得……肖恩正在想一个……你们其中一个在想一个生物。我正在进行谷歌搜索。你知道吗，我经常在一周中间想出很多这样的词，然后就把它们给忘了。这是个好故事。你应该用这个开头。你知道吗，我听说“美洲野 bison”会是个不错的话题。
We did? We've done that a million times. Yeah. It's such a stupid thing that we're doing. You've been saying it's stupid since day one. But every single time we get to it, it's insane to me. And now it's just ironic that we're doing like, it's so dumb that we just decided, well, it's so dumb, let's just still do it.
我们说过吗？我们已经说过一百万次了。对。我们做这件事真是蠢透了。你从第一天起就说这很蠢。但每次我们说到这儿，我都觉得太疯狂了。现在我们做这件事简直具有讽刺意味，太蠢了，我们只是决定——好吧，这太蠢了，那我们还是继续做吧。
Yeah, so you don't want to do it? By the way, we don't have to think of so dumb, let's just still do it. You know? And it's just. So you don't want to do it? By the way, we don't have to think of a word, we could just say goodbye. Well, yeah, how would you wrap this thing up without a. I have one that would work perfectly for. I would say you just make your situation, listen, we're in a situation that you don't like,
对啊，所以你不想做？顺便说一句，我们不用去想……这太蠢了，那我们还是继续做吧。你知道吗？这就……所以你不想做？顺便说一句，我们不用去想一个词，我们可以直接说再见。好吧，对，你怎么能在没有……的情况下结束这档节目呢？我有一个完美契合的。我会说，你只是让你的处境……听着，我们身处一个你不喜欢的处境，
and you don't like that we're in this situation, and Jason, I'm gonna put it in golf terms. I'm gonna put it in golf terms. Oh, that's great, thanks. So sometimes you hit a good drive and you go down the middle of the thing. But you know, it's a little bit, and you know what you can always do?
而你又不喜欢我们身处这个处境，杰森，我用高尔夫术语来表达吧。我用高尔夫术语来表达。哦，太棒了，谢谢。所以有时候你打出一个好球，球落在了球道正中央。但你知道，这有点……你知道你总是能做什么吗？
You can always improve your life. No, not cutting it. Okay. That's. I was gonna say, wait, it's right there. It's right there. He's Pete Buttigieg. He was in office.
你总是可以改善你的生活。不，这行不通。好吧。这……我正要说，等等，它就在那儿。它就在那儿。他是皮特·布蒂吉格。他曾担任公职。
He reached across the aisle. He was very, he was very, very bipartisan. Bye. See you next week. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
他跨越党派。他非常、非常两党合作。再见。下周见。聪明。精简。聪明。精简。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿姆贾夫（Rob Armjarf）和贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）100%有机纯手工打造。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。